SUPPOSED TO BE A ONE TIME AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE THIS
IS THE TIME SET.
FOR OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY TO MEET -- WE WILL
KNOW TO OR I SHOULD NOTE -- FOR
THOSE OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE
THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI HAS BEEN
PULLED.
MANY WILL BE HEARD TODAY SO IF
YOU'RE HERE FOR THAT YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO STAY BUT IF
THAT'S THE REASON YOU'RE HERE
EXCLUSIVELY YOU MIGHT FIND OTHER
THINGS OF GREATER INTEREST FOR
YOU TO DO BUT YOU'RE ALWAYS
WELCOME -- WE DO HAVE FIVE ITEMS
ON THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY.
THEY ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB SIX EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM FILE ITEM SIX AB EIGHT
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
FILE ITEM TEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
WITH AMENDMENTS AND FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
AND WITH THAT OF WE WILL --
TURNED TO TODAY'S OTHER MEASURES
WE WILL START OFF AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE -- BUT IF THE
SERGEANT COULD TRY TO GET SOME
MEMBERS HERE I KNOW SEVERAL OR
IN OTHER COMMITTEES AS WELL --
SO WE WILL JUST DO OUR BEST
WHILE WE WAIT.
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO BE HERE AND
WE WILL START [inaudible]
WITH -- FILE ITEM.
ONE WHICH IS AB ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STEP FORWARD -- THE THE
WAY WE TRY TO CONDUCT THINGS IN
THIS COMMITTEE -- I WILL ASK
THAT FOR EACH MEASURE THERE BE
TWO MAIN WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES
EACH FOR SUPPORT -- AT WHICH
POINT IN TIME ANY OTHER PEOPLE
HERE IN SUPPORT WILL BE ASKED TO
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE --
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AN INDICATION OF THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
THAT WILL BE IT -- NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION AT THAT POINT IN TIME --
THEN WE WILL INTRODUCE THE
OPPOSITION.
THEY WILL HAVE TO WITNESSES A
MAXIMUM OF TWO MINUTES EACH AND
THEN WE WILL REPEAT THE PROCESS
OPPOSITION TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND INDICATE THEIR OPPOSITION --
AND THAT WAY WE WILL BE OUT HERE
AT A FAIRLY REASONABLE HOUR SO --
LET'S SEE WITH THEIR TO WE NEED
ONE MORE PERSON SO IF WE HAVE
ONE MORE WILL INTERRUPT THE
PROCEEDINGS TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT IN THE MEANTIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING ON FILE
ITEM.
AB YEAH FILE ITEM ONE AB ONE
SIXTY ONE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER
FIRST ON THE THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS.
BILL -- WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AS AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE -- WITH
PAPER RECEIPTS.
THE GENERATE.
THEY HAVE A GARDEN.
CREATE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WASTE.
WE AT THIS WE KNOW THAT THREE
MILLION TREES NINE BILLION
GALLONS OF WATER -- ACTUALLY ARE
USED TO GENERATE PEOPLE PAPER
RECEIPTS GENERATES ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION POUNDS
OF WASTE FOUR MILLION POUNDS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE.
ARE AB ONE SIXTY ONE WE BELIEVE
IS A VERY SOUND SOLUTION ON HOW
TO REDUCE.
THE WASTE WITHIN PAPER RECEIPTS
ON IN ADDITION WE LEAVE
CONSUMERS THE OPTION TO ALWAYS
REQUEST A PAPER RECEIPT TO HAVE
THAT ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO THEM
SHOULD THEY ACTUALLY WANT A
PAPER RECEIPT AND SHOULD THEY
ACTUALLY.
REQUESTED WE AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
TO REMOVE THE DIGITAL RECEIPT
MANDATED BEEN ALSO -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL HELP RESOLVE THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS THAT -- MANY
PEOPLE HAD SHARED IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES -- WE ALSO -- WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT ONE AMENDMENTS
WAS STARTING IN JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REQUIRES EVER
SEATS BE REPAIRABLE UPON REQUEST
AND FOR THOSE RECEIPTS TO BE.
AYE BPA IN B. PS FREE.
AS YOU ARE PROBABLY AWARE
THERE'S A STUDY OUT THERE THAT
ABOUT 93% OF BESI PAPERS ARE
COATED WITH PPA OR BE PS WHICH
IS A VERY WELL DOCUMENTED TOXIC
SUBSTANCE SO.
I EVEN IF PEOPLE WANT PAPER SEES
WE THINK IT'S REALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR US TO GIVE THEM.
A PROCEEDS THAT REALLY ARE NOT
TOXIC ON IN WITHOUT LET ME JUST
TURN OVER TO MY TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST
WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE
ACTION A CORPUS OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE.
THIS BILL SIR TARGETS AS SOME OF
THE LOWEST HANGING FRUIT AND WE
SAW THIS LAST YEAR WITH THE
STRUGGLE -- THERE ARE CATEGORIES
OF PRODUCTS THAT WE ARE HANDED.
THAT WE LITERALLY CARRIED TO THE
NEXT TRASH CAN AND THROW AWAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PRODUCTS --
IF WE CAN'T AT THE VERY LEAST
ALLOW PEOPLE TO NOT TAKE
SOMETHING THEY DON'T WANT.
AND THERE'S NO WAY WE'RE GONNA
CHIEF ARE MORE IMPRESSIVE AN
AMBITIOUS.
GOALS AT FIRST SEATS
SPECIFICALLY THEY ARE OFTEN -- A
CONTAMINANT IN THE RECYCLING
STREAM -- THAT B. P. SMB PA AND
UP IN THE RECYCLED MATERIALS AS
WELL.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF LOGICAL
REASONS TO DO THIS BUT BASIC
COMES DOWN TO LET'S AT LEAST LET
WANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
SHORT AND SWEET NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE BILL ALLEY -- FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP WE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL SINCE ITS
INCEPTION FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
REASONS -- WHICH IS EXPOSURE TO
BYZANTINE ALL I AM VISITING ALL
**** SB SINGLE FULL FIGHT.
OF BOTH ARE UNKNOWN TOXICANTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE
BAD FOR ESPECIALLY FOR OF
PREGNANT WOMEN A LOT OF CASHIERS
SOMETIMES ARE PREGNANT AND THEIR
EXPOSURE IS HIGH WHEN THEY'RE
WORKING WITH THESE RECEIPTS.
ON A DAILY BASIS AND MOST OF
MARK COMPLETELY UNAWARE.
OF THEIR EXPOSURE SO AB ONE
SIXTY ONE WILL HELP ELIMINATE
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH SHOULD
BE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF
YOU'D STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON TREE SEBERG **** ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE MOORE ON BEHALF OF
ONCOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AS AMENDED YES THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN I THINK THEY'RE NOTED --
AND YOU MAY HAVE MISSED IT BUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING IF YOU'LL
ADDRESS SAID AGAIN IN YOUR
CLOTHES THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MARGARET GLAD SEEN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE DO
CONTINUE TO STILL OPPOSE THE
BILL WE THINK THIS IS A PROBLEM
FOR SEVERAL REASONS THE NO
RECEIPT IS VERY MUCH A PROBLEM
FOR MANY OF OUR MEMBERS.
RECEIPTS ARE IMPORTANT TOOL TO
HELP US PREVENT -- THEFT AND
THEY'RE IMPORTANT LOSS
PREVENTION TOOL OUR A SALES
ASSOCIATE SOMETIMES ASK PEOPLE
TO SEE THEM T THE DOOR OR AS A
ROLE AS THEY HAVE LEFT THE STORE.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT TOOL FOR THAT --
AS YOU RECALL THE VOTERS PASSED
PROP ONE PROP PASSED PROP --
FORTY SEVEN THAT'S IT'S A NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLAR SAFT
LIMIT IN EVERYTHING BELOW THAT
IS A MISDEMEANOR WE NOW SEE
CRIMINALS COMING IN THE STORE
WITH CALCULATORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY STAY BELOW THAT LEVEL.
AND SO THIS IS TAKING AWAY ONE
MORE TOOL FOR US IN LOSS
PREVENTION.
OUT ALSO NOTE THAT MANY STORES
HAVE A RECEIPT REQUIREMENT FOR
RETURNS AND SO IF A CUSTOMER
DECIDES THEY DON'T WANT TO
RECEIVE AT THE POINT OF SALE AND
THEN WANTS TO BRING SOMETHING
BACK -- THEY'LL BE FRUSTRATED
WITH THE RETAILER BECAUSE THEY
CHOSE NOT TO GET A RECEIPT ALSO
IT IS EASY -- FOR CONSUMERS WHO
WANT TO HAVE STOLEN SOMETHING
WANT TO BRING BACK A RECEIPT TO
DUMMY UP A RECEIPT -- AND COMMIT
RECEIPT FRAUD IT SOMETHING WE
FIGHT EVERY DAY THE OTHER THING
THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IS
THE LIMITATION ON WHAT WE CAN
PRINT ON THESE.
A RECEIPT FOR NON ESSENTIAL
ITEMS -- YOU'RE INCREASING THE
COST WITH THE MATERIAL
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS YEAR ALSO
RESTRICTING OUR ABILITIES HELP
PEOPLE ON TO GO SOMETIMES ON
RECEIPTS WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
VOTE RIGHT BEFORE ELECTION DAY
WE COURAGE PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CENSUS.
WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO MAKE
CHARITABLE DONATIONS AS WELL AS
OFFERING COUPONS AND
ADVERTISEMENTS ENCOURAGING GO TO
OUR WEBSITE SO ALL OF THESE
THINGS WOULD BE POTENTIALLY
CONSIDERED NONESSENTIAL ITEMS
THAT MAY NOT FIT ON THE RECEIPT
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE KNOW THERE BEEN
ISSUES ABOUT COUPONS BUT THOSE
COUPONS OF HELP SAVE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR JUST FROM A
SMALL NUMBER OF RETAILERS ALONE.
THESE CONCERNS ALL MAKE IT
HARDER FOR BRICK AND MORTAR
RETAILERS TO OPERATE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THIS
LEGISLATURE'S ASKING US TO
ALREADY COLLECT POINT OF SALE
FEES.
BE THE POINT OF CONTACT OR THAT
THE TAKE BACK RECEPTACLE FOR
MANY DIFFERENT ITEMS YOU WANT US
TO AN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE'RE
COMPETING AGAINST.
ONLINE SALES THIS MAKES IT
HARDER AND HARDER FOR BURKE IN
ORDER TO OPERATE OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO
TO THE NEXT WITNESS A WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM SO MADAM SECRETARY
LET'S ESTABLISH THE QUARTER.
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
BORDERS. FOR JUST HERE TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HERE JONES.
JONES HERE MONNING [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
WHAT CASKEY WHAT HEALTHCARE?
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT.
TO WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND MATT CERTAIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AS WELL -- WE ARE
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DIFFERENT
EATING ESTABLISHMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE MOST OF WHICH WOULD BE
YOUR SMALL INDEPENDENT COMMUNITY
BASED RESTAURANTS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THIS BILL
WILL IMPACT US AND I WANT TO
TOUCH ON THREE DIFFERENT ISSUES
THE EXEMPTIONS THE PRODUCT
LIMITATION MEANING THE PAPER --
AND THEN THE CONTENT
RESTRICTIONS ON OUR
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR GUESTS.
FIRST OF ALL -- WITH REGARD TO
THIS SMALL BUSINESS EXEMPTIONS I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TO YOU.
THAT THESE ARE STRUCTURED IN A
WAY -- THAT ARE BASED ON GROSS
RECEIPTS AND GROSS RECEIPTS DO
NOT ALWAYS TELL YOU WHETHER A
RESTAURANT IS LARGE OR SMALL --
WERE RETAIL FOR THAT MATTER
GROSS RECEIPTS IS A NUMBER
THAT'S THAT'S DRIVEN BY FOOT
TRAFFIC IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WE SEE.
IN A GIVEN ESTABLISHMENT EACH
DAY -- AND DEPENDING ON YOUR
GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENTIALS ON
COSTS IN GEOGRAPHY AND PRICES
AND REAL ESTATE YOUR GROSS
RECEIPTS WILL VERY DRAMATICALLY
AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE THE
POINTS YOU THE GROSS RECEIPTS
DON'T DICTATE WHETHER YOUR A BIG
OR SMALL FOOT PRINT.
OR WHETHER YOU EMPLOY A LOT OF
PEOPLE OR A FEW PEOPLE SO WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS AN
ADEQUATE -- EXEMPTION AND WE DO
THINK THAT THIS WILL APPLY TO
MANY SMALL RETAILERS AND SMALL
RESTAURANTS IN PARTICULAR.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THE PAPER
THE LIMITATION ON THE PRODUCT
THE PAPER HAS TO BE BPA OR BE PS
FREE.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
HERE AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT TO YOU THAT THAT IS
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF THE
SUPPLY OF RECEIPT PAPER THAT WE
CAN USE.
WHICH IS THE END USERS OF THE
RECEIPT PAPER SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SUPPLIERS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CREATE THAT
AMOUNTS OF BPA AND BE PS FREE
PAPER -- AND I KNOW THE BILL
WOULD IN THIS SITUATIONWOULD
TAKE EFFECT IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHAT WE DID SEE WITH THE STRAW
BAN.
WAS THAT WE DID SEE A HUGE RUN
ON STRAW PURCHASES OF COURSE --
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
FOR SUPPLIERS TO MEET THE DEMAND
OF ALL THE NEWS DROP PURCHASES
WE FEAR THAT MIGHT HAPPEN WITH
THE BPA AND BE PS FREE PAPER.
AND SO WE WANT TO BE SENSITIVE
TO THAT.
AND THEN THE LAST ISSUE IS
LIMITING THE CONTENT ON RECEIPTS
WE USE RECEIPTS AS A WAY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR GUESTS ALL
THE TME WE DO IT TO CELEBRATE
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR WORKFORCE
WE DO IT TO ADVERTISE CHARITY
PROGRAMS AND ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO IT FOR
SURVEYS IF I MAY JUST RANK YOU
WOULD GET FOR TEN MINUTES ELEVEN
SECONDS THIS IS GOING TO SET A
BAD TREND.
SO IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
WILL CERTAINLY INVITE THEM.
OUR OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU PLEASE COME
FOR WITH YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
pOF AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE REPRESENTING OVER --
TWELVE THOUSAND GAS STATIONS A
CONVENIENCE STORES IN THE STATE
WE WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE RESTAURANTS THE STATION ON
THE SMALL BUSINESS IMPACT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR TOM
SHE HE REPRESENTING THE
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI SEAN LUIS NATIONAL VOTERS
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HALF OF THE FOREST
PRODUCTS INDUSTRY NATIONAL LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CAPPING LUNCH REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KESSLER
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
ON ALL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SEVEN ANDRSON ON BEHALF OF
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND WESTERN CAR WASH ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AFTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM RILEY
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DYESS THE SENATOR ALSO DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YES -- I I DO HAVE BY MYSELF
UNUSUAL UNUSUALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT A NUMBER OF OF THINGS -- I
DO THINK THAT THERE WHAT I'VE
HEARD THAT THERE IS -- A VALID
CONCERN ABOUT LOSS PREVENTION --
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SO I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY WHAT THE SOLUTION
IS BUT I DO SEE HOW THAT IS -- A
VERY VALID CONCERN I DIDN'T KNOW
THERE WAS AN ISSUE WITH RECEIPT
FRAUD SO I DON'T KNOW HOW BIG IT
IS BUT THAT JUST CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION -- WITH REGARDS TO THE
RECEIPTS -- AS THEIR BEEN
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE VOLUNTARY --
USE OF RECEIPTS LIKE THE
CUSTOMER IS THAT INCLUDED IN
YOUR AND I DIDN'T TWO IS SET TO
THE AUTHOR YES YEAH SO THEY ARE
ON WE WE HAVE HAD -- CONVERSES
WITH RETAILERS ABOUT DIFFERENT
OPTIONS -- THERE THAT'S WHY WE
PUT THE BILL WHERE IT'S RECEIPT
UPON DEMAND YOU CAN EITHER ASK
FOR NO RECEIVED AS FOR PAPER
RECEIPT.
IT REALLY GIVES YOU THOSE
OPTIONS AND THEN WHAT WE FOCUSED
ON IN TERMS OF THE PAPER.
IT IS REALLY WHAT THE USE OF THE
PAPER WAS THOSE OF THE
AMENDMENTS WE TOOK OUT OF
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS. TO
REALLY LIMIT THE RECEIPT TO THE
RECEIPT NOT TERM MARKETING
MATERIAL IN FACT I THOUGHT THE
SENATE.
ANALYSIS POINTED OUT -- QUITE
QUITE WELL AN ARTICLE THAT SAID --
THE A PARTICULAR BE TO I'M NOT
GONNA GO INTO THE PARTICULAR
RETAILER BUT THEIR RECEIPT WAS
OVER THREE FEET LONGER THAN IT
EITHER NOT SOMEONE ELSE'S
TYPICAL RISKY.
AND THEY'RE FAIRLY FAMOUS FOR
THEIR VERY LONG RECEIPTS AND
THIS IS EXCLUDING THE RECEIPT
AND THE COUPONS [inaudible]
HA.
I'M AND THE ISSUE OF THE PAPER
AND THE IS THE PAPER AND THE INK.
THE THE PAPER IT IS A TOXIC.
THE IT IS IT'S ACTUALLY PAPER
ITSELF THE PAPERS OFFICE COATED
WITH -- BPA SLASH PPS -- THAT IS
THE PART THAT'S TOXIC BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES THAT CHEMICAL SO THAT
THE INQUIRIES SHOULD ON THE
PAPER CAPTION.
UHHUH.
AND WHAT ARE THE ALTERNATIVES TO
THAT THAT ARE READILY AVAILABLE
OR WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THAT.
WELL THAT'S WHAT WE ALSO WAITED
TO BEGIN THE BILL'S NOT GOING
INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO THERE'S
TIME. TO TRANSITION -- AGAIN BUT
THE STUDY SAYS THAT 93% OF THE
RECEIPTS ARE USING THIS KIND OF
PAPER SO THAT MEANS 7% AREN'T
AND SO THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES
OUT THERE.
BUT THAT'S I GUESS THAT'S TO MY
NEXT QUESTION IS.
THE WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO MAKE.
THE PAPER NOT [inaudible]
TOXIC.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE
INVESTMENT THAT READILY
AVAILABLE IS THAT A BIG PROBLEM
WHAT.
WHAT IS THE?
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES AS FAR AS?
USING THEM AND NEEDING THEM AND
WANTING THE RECEIPTS HOW DO YOU
DEAL WITH THAT PROBLEM OF THE
PAPER SAYS TO THE PAPER THAT WE
USE TODAY THE PAPER THAT YOU'RE
USING TURN TO RETURN MATERIALS
IS.
NOT LAYS WITH PPA PPS FOR THE
PAPER ITSELF IS.
READILY AVAILABLE -- IN TERMS OF
HOW IT INTERFACES WITH THE
DIFFERENT RETAIL MACHINES I
THINK THAT WOULD BE PROBABLY
BETTER IN A BETTER QUESTION TO
ASK THE DIFFERENT RETAILERS -- I
DID ONE OF THOSE SINCE IT SHOULD
MENTION ALSO LOSS PREVENTION --
I THINK THAT -- GET SOMETHING
THAT WE HAD TALKED TO THE
RETAILERS ABOUT THAT IS A
CONCERN.
HAVING SAID THAT MOST RETAILERS
DON'T CHECK YOUR RECEIPT UPON
EXITING THERE'S ONLY A COUPLE
THAT ARE FAIRLY WELL KNOWN COSCO
BEST BUY FOR EXAMPLE -- MOST OF
THE RETAILERS IF YOU'RE IN A
SUPERMARKET I I SHOP AT
WALGREENS OR THE CVS OR RITE AID
AND I CAN'T RECALL THE LAST TIME
I WAS STOPPED -- UPON EXITING
PUMP PAYING AN ACCIDENT SO CAN I
UNDERSTAND THE LOSS PREVENTION
ISSUE THAT THERE DEFINITELY HAS
BEEN A BROADER ISSUE BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THE RECEIPTS ARE THE THE
RECEIPT OR THE LACK OF RECEIPTS
IS REALLY.
THE ISSUE THE THE CHALLENGE WITH
LOSS PREVENTIONS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE.
BEEN A CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES THAT
ARE ORGANIZED IN ARE GOING INTO
STORES AND STEALING THINGS I
DON'T THINK.
THEY'RE GONNA STOP BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE RECEIPTS OR DON'T
HAVE.
FOR SIX I THINK THERE'S A FEW
MORE STORES ARE STARTING TO USE
AT HOME DEPOT DOZEN SOME OF THE
ONES BUT ANYWAY YEAH.
I I DON'T LIST ALL OF THEM YEAH.
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THE ISSUE
OF THE PAPER.
CERTAINLY -- WE DO KNOW THAT THE
B. P. A. B. P. S. FREE PAPER IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE --
NEED IT AB FOR OUR MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE REPRESENT LARGER AT RETAILERS --
IT CAN BE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OR EVEN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER
YEAR -- SOME OF OUR POINT OF
SALE SYSTEMS WILL NEED TO BE --
SIGNIFICANTLY REPROGRAMMED TO
DEAL WITH THIS SOME OF THEM
AUTOMATICALLY PRODUCE RECEIPTS
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS.
AND IF I MAY I'D ALSO SAY THAT --
THE LOSS PREVENTION IS A PIECE
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO US WE DON'T
CHECK EVERY CUSTOMER IN EVERY
ONE OF OUR STORES BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
US.
IT IS ONE OF THE FEW TOOLS THAT
WE HAVE TO HELP REDUCE THEFT IN
OUR STORES I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION THAT EUROPE DOES HAVE B.
P. FREE SO THIS ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT CAN'T BE DONE -- AND IT'S
ALREADY BEING DONE IN EUROPE SO
I ASSUME THAT THEY WOULD.
BE ABLE TO FIGURE THIS ONE OUT
WITHOUT SPENDING ENORMOUS COSTS
THAT'S AN ISSUE ACTUALLY IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
IN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY THE OB.
THE CONCERNS ABOUT -- THE LOSS
PREVENTION -- IS ONE ARGUABLY --
THAT IS MORE WITHIN OUR PURVIEW
ARE ISSUES ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
THE FINES AND THE FACT THAT THEY
DID THE TOOK THE AMENDMENTS --
WHICH REMOVE THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS WE HAD AND FRANKLY THE
PENALTY I ISSUES ARE WITHIN OUR
PURVIEW BUT IT'S TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY WITH A MAXIMUM
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR SO
THAT.
CAN'T REALLY BE THE MAJOR.
DETERMINANT OF THE OPPOSITION --
BUT PERHAPS AT SOME POINT WE CAN
GET THAT RE FOCUSED ON THE LOSS
PREVENTION.
OF CENTER WHY KASKI THOUGH THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MADAM CHAIR WE
NORMALLY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
BILLS ON COMMERCIAL SPEECH SO
IT'S THAT'S A FUN THING MY
QUESTION WAS ON THE STAFF REPORT.
AT PAGE TWELVE IT'S REMOVING THE
AMENDMENT ON THIS ON PURPOSE
BEVERLY CREDIT ACT [inaudible]
IT WAS.
IS THAT JUST A PORTION OF IT OR
IS IT THE WHOLE -- PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING LANGUAGE THAT WAS IN
THERE I JUST [inaudible]
THEN.
IT'S THOSE PROVISIONS ARE
COMPLETELY OUT THE BECAUSE THIS
IS A MOVEMENT AMENDMENT MIGHT
THAT WAS OR SOME OTHER THING IT
WAS A IT WAS A PORTION OF IT IN
IN IN MY STATUS TELL ME HE WAS A
PORTION THAT WE HAD ADDED THAT
WE ARE TAKING OUT.
THAT DEALS WITH YOUR PURSE LIKE
THAT AFFECTS NO LONGER NEEDED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NO LONGER
MANDATING THE RECEIPTS PERFECT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
RIGHT -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THE CONCERNS HERE I WOULD
LIKE YOU WHEN YOU'RE CLOSE TO
ADDRESS.
THE ISSUE OF LOSS PREVENTION YOU
KNOW I THINK THE YOU CAN SEND AN
EMAIL RECEIPT WE GET A LOT OF
THOSE NOW -- BUT WHAT ABOUT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE.
I KNOW THEY'RE PROBABLY AT LEAST
TEN PEOPLE IN THE STATE THAT
DON'T HAVE AN IPHONE OR
SOMETHING BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS COULD BE ARGUABLY AN ISSUE
FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS.
HOW DO YOU DRESS THAT RECEIPT IF
YOU WANT TO RETURN AN ITEM?
SO THAT YOU CAN IN FACT DO SO
AND OTHER THAN THAT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON THE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MANAGER REALLY
APPRECIATE AGAIN ALL ALL THE
WORK FOR YOUR COMMITTEE IN TERMS
OF LOSS PREVENTION AGAIN ANY
INDIVIDUAL CAN STILL HOUSE FOR A
PAPER.
OF THE FUEL THAT'S WHAT THEY
FEEL THEY WANT BEFORE THEY WALK
OUT THE STORE THEY HAVE THAT
RIGHT THEY HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
GET THAT RECEIPT.
IN TERMS OF LOSS PREVENTION.
FRANKLY THE MOST PROFITABLE
RETAILER YOU JUST MENTIONED THEM.
IN IN THIS COUNTRY ON A PER
SQUARE FOOT BASIS AS APPLE AND
THEY FRANKLY HAVE BEEN AT LEAST
N THE BAY AREA PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST HIGH PROFILE TARGETS OF
THEFT.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO APPLE
STORES AND STEALING APPLE
WATCHES AND GRABBING PHONES AND
ALL THAT SORT OF STUFF?
BUT THE ONE THING YOU CAN'T GET
AT APPLE STORES A PAPER SEE.
APPLE HAS BEEN PAPERLESS FOR
QUITE AWHILE AND IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE A PURCHASE YOU CAN DO MANY
THINGS BUT YOU CAN'T GET A PAPER
SEAT NOT AN APPLE STORE. TO
RETAILERS ARE ALREADY MOVING IN
THIS DIRECTION IF YOU GO ACROSS
THE STREET GET A CUP OF COFFEE
CHECKER YOU MIGHT REALIZE THEY
OFFER YOU MANY THINGS IN OFFER
PAPERS.
SO -- THE PAPER RECEIPTS RIGHT
NOW AGAIN I TALKED ABOUT THE
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF WASTE.
ON TOP OF THAT THEY CONTAMINATE
OUR WASTE STREAM.
SO IF YOU WANT TO RECYCLE THE
PAPER IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
RECYCLE IF YOU WANNA COMPOST
PAPER THERE'S ONE THING I
LEARNED I DID LEARN TWICE ARE
CARRYING THIS BILL IF YOU WANT A
COMPOST THIS PAPER.
IT RUINS YOUR COMPOST.
YOU CANNOT PUT IN YOUR COMPOST
SO IF YOU GET A RECEIPT.
THAT'S YOUR AGREES WITH PAPER
THE PIZZA BOX CAN GO INTO THE
COMPOST.
THE RECEIPT CAN'T BECAUSE IT IS
LAYS WITH THIS TOXIC CHEMICAL SO
AGAIN.
WE WE THINK THIS IS SOMETHING TO
REALLY MAKE US AS CALIFORNIA'S
RETHINK HOW WE ARE USING A
PARTICULAR KIND OF PRODUCT WE
NEED TO BE MUCH SMARTER ABOUT
OUR WASTE WHETHER IT'S PLASTIC
OR PAPER -- WE THINK THIS IS A
VERY SMALL STEP AGAIN TO
CONSUMERS HAVE EVERY ABILITY. TO
ASK FOR THIS PAPER CA WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS MY STAFF WAS
SAYING -- THERE'S AN ESTIMATE TO
SWITCH OUT A ROLL OF PAPER OF
THE BPA PAPER VERSUS THE TOXIC
FREE PAPERS.
BUT EVENTUALLY ADDITIONAL SEVEN
DOLLARS A BOX SO WE THINK THAT
THIS CAN BE DONE -- THAT IS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED EUROPE WE THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE THE LEAD ON IT'S ALWAYS
DIFFICULT TO LEAD -- AND SO YOU
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH EVIDENCE IN
TERMS OF OTHER STATES.
WERE CALIFORNIA WE THINK WE CAN
DO THIS AND WE FRANKLY HAVE PUT
A NUMBER PROVISIONS AND
EXEMPTIONS WITHIN SMALL BUSINESS
AGAIN WE RAISE THE EXEMPTION
FROM ONE MILLION TO TWO MILLION.
SO IN ORDER TO BE IMPACTED --
YOU HAVE TO BE GROSSING MORE
THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TERMS OF RESTAURANTS.
YOU CAN STILL GIVE A PAPER
RECEIPT ME WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET
THE INVOICE QUITE OFTEN WHEN THE
RESTAURANT BRINGS YOU A BILL.
THE BILL IS PAPER -- HI I'M
PROBABLY LIKE MANY OF THE PEOPLE
HI A PAY WITH A CREDIT CARD I
SIGNED THE BILL AND I LEAVE ALL
THE PAPER THERE I DON'T TAKE THE
RESTAURANT RECEIPTS WITH ME
UNLESS I'M.
NEEDING TO HANDED OVER AS SOME
SORT OF ACCOUNTS PROBABLY SMART
BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE THEM REALIZE
THE ACURELATION OF TIME SHE
VITON OUT THE COST OF EATING OUT
YOU PROBABLY WOULD BE BETTER OFF
NOT KNOWING.
THANK YOU FAIR ENOUGH.
AT LEAST THAT'S BEEN MY PROBLEM.
THE SPECIALLY APPEARANCE
SACRAMENTO -- BUT BUT AGAIN I I
THINK -- I THINK WE FRANKLY PUT
A NUMBER PROVISIONS TO REALLY
MAKE THIS TRANSITION I FAIRLY
SEAMLESS TRANSITION.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR ALL
YOUR WORK WITH US AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR AB
ONE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
BYE WELL AS OF CENTER AKOWSKI
MENTIONED THERE IS THIS WHOLE
QUESTION ALSO OF ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THE RECEIPTS --
YOU KNOW IT'S TO IT.
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT -- I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT.
BECAUSE SITE I THINK IT HELPS US
KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING
ABOUT MOVING INTO THE FUTURE AYE.
I DON'T THINK THE SKY IS FALLING
THERE MAY BE SOME CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
AND ODD GOES TO EQ THESE THESE
BPA THIS IS.
THIS IS TOXIC STUFF IN RIGHT
AFTER EATING A MEAL YOU GET THAT
RECEIPT AT A RESTAURANT -- AT
YOU KNOW YOUR FINGERS IN NOW --
ENDED DOES BLEED INTO THE SKIN
DOES IT NOT THESE ARE AT THE I
MEAN THESE ARE SERIOUSLY TOXIC
MATERIALS.
BUT AGAIN THAT IS THE EQ --
COMMITTEES.
ISSUE -- BUT I I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I I THINK
IT'S A CONVERSATION WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE HAVING -- AND OF COURSE
THE THIS IS.
THE ISSUES OF RELATIVE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ARE HAVE
NARROWED IS CONSIDERABLY SO I
DON'T.
FEEL THAT COMPELLED [inaudible]
TO TO UP YOU KNOW.
ENCOURAGE OTHERS WHO MAY NOT.
THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA BUT I
DO AND SO -- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN AND IT WITH
YOUR UNDER A COMMITMENT THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AND SOME
THESE CAN ACTUALLY WE WE HD
SOME MOCKING PRODUCTIVE INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WERE STILL WAITING
FOR FEEDBACK FROM THE RETAILERS
IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE CAN.
WE CAN DO TO HELP THEM SATISFY
THEIR NEEDS AS WELL TO OPERATE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
THERE IS IS YOUR MOTION
[inaudible]
THE MOVE.
ALL RIGHT OF US WILL HAVE CENTER
MONNING MOVE THIS ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED THE SENATE HE Q.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
AND THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED SO WITH THAT PLEASE SIR
MA'AM SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE SIX
ONE JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE BOARD
JUST -- RUSSELL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I'D JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN -- BERG Y.
CASKEY RIGHT HOUSE THE I THIS
YEAR.
ALL RIGHT THE OTHER COUNT IS
FORTY ZERO WILL PLACE THE MATTER
CALL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR TESTIFYING
ON THAT BILL -- AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE -- I KNOW THE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA IS CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND TO HIM.
THE COURTESY THE TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY SO WE CAN GO BACK TO
HIS COMMITTEE IT'S A RATHER FULL
HOUSE THERE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINE OF FILE ITEM NINE IS AB.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR YOUR WITNESSES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TODAY I PRESENT A. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX UNDER CURRENT
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE CALIFORNIA
PAWN BROKERS.
COME BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE.
EVERY FIVE YEARS TO GET
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL. TO ADJUST
THEIR MAXIMUM RATES AND FEES TO
OFFSET THE INCREASED COST OF
OPERATION.
THIS BILL WOULD JUST ALONE SET
UP FEE TO THE GREATER OF EITHER
SEVEN DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS.
FOR THREE AND ONE HALF PERCENT.
OF THE LOAN BALANCE BUT NOT TO
EXCEED NINETY DOLLARS.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX ATTEMPTS TO
KEEP THE POND INDUSTRY
FINANCIALLY VIABLE IN TODAY'S
LENDING MARKET.
EACH OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OFFICES OF BEEN PROVIDED WITH A
COPY OF THE OF THE REPORT.
PREPARED BY THE INDUSTRY THAT
OUTLINES THE OPERATIONAL COST
INCREASES SINCE THE LAST
ADJUSTMENT WHICH BECAME
EFFECTIVE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND SB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE THIS BILL AS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND NO NO VOTES HERE WITH ME
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAWN BROKERS
ASSOCIATION.
IS BILL THE ****.
THERE'S A MOTION AND NO
OPPOSITION SO PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO MAKE IT NICE AND SHORT AND
SWEET.
I WILL DO EXACTLY THAT SENATOR.
THE MANAGER MEN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF BOTH -- THE
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE I HAVE
WITH ME HERE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE JAN
SCHNEIDER WHO IS A STAND AS A
PAWNBROKER AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES OR ANY
OTHER PEOPLE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
MARCHING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
OF THE MOTION IS SAID TO PASS.
TO THE SENATE FLOOR AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE THAT BILLIONS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE VERY GOOD.
OF THE MOTION TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX JACKSON
JACKSON AYE BORCHERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN AMBERG LIKE
OWSKI WHY BECAUSE THE AYE. FIVE
TO ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND GOOD
LUCK BACK IN YOUR COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME LONGER
DOLPH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE.
I WAS JUST OVER AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA IS -- COMMITTEE
AND IT IS FULL OF PEOPLE AND I
THOUGHT I'D GET HIM BACK THERE --
AS QUICKLY AS WE COULD SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE NO
WORRIES HE IS.
THIS IS HOW WHILE ITEMS TO AB.
TWO FORTY TWO GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU WILL GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- FIRST
I WANT TO SAY THAT I DO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU FOR THOSE.
I AM PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FOUR TWO WHICH WILL REQUIRE
ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES TO PARTAKE
IN CONTINUAL EDUCATION ON
IMPLICIT BIAS.
EVERY THREE YEARS AND COURT
PERSONNEL EVERY TWO YEARS.
IMPLICIT BIASES THE UNCONSCIOUS
AND UNINTENTIONAL MENTAL SHORT
CUT THAT HUMAN BEINGS CAN
DEVELOP AND IT IMPACTS US ALL.
IT IS OFTEN THE SUBTLE
ASSOCIATIONS WE MAKE BETWEEN
GROUPS OF PEOPLE AND STEREOTYPES
ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE -- MY OTHER
WITNESS WHO UNFORTUNATELY WAS
NOT ABLE TO STAY -- TALKS ABOUT
THE NEURAL SCIENCE BEHIND --
IMPLICIT BIAS AND THE WAYS IN
WHICH DIFFERENT TRIGGERS COME
OFF AT DIFFERENT TIMES WHICH
INFORMS HOW WE TREAT OUR OTHER
FOLKS THAT -- EITHER LOOK LIKE
US OR DO NOT LOOK LIKE US.
MOST OF US WOULD LIKE TO BE FREE
FOR OF BIAS ATTITUDES AND
STEREOTYPES THAT LEAD US TO
JUDGE PEOPLE BASED ON THE SOCIAL
CATEGORIES THAT THEY BELONG.
TO SUCH AS RACE AGE GENDER
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND ETHNICITY.
BUT DESPITE PEOPLE'S BEST
INTENTIONS RESEARCHERS HAVE
FOUND THAT SUBJECTS CAN
CONSCIOUSLY EMBRACE IDEAS OF
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY AND YET ON
TESTS THAT MEASURE SUB CONSCIOUS
TENDENCIES STILL SHOW A STRONG
PROPENSITY TO LEAN ON STEREO
TYPES.
THE FILL IN THE BLANKS ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT ATTORNEYS
JUDGES AND COURT PERSONNEL
RECEIVE TRAINING ON A ROUTINE
BASIS TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
IMPLICIT BIAS SEES AND TAKES
STEPS TO COUNTERACT THEIR
UNCONSCIOUS INFLUENCES.
UNCONSCIOUS AN IMPLICIT BIAS
SEES CAN AND DO AFFECT THE DAY
TO DAY DECISION MAKING PROCESS
SEES EVEN THE MOST AWARE COURT
OFFICERS.
GET CHANGE CAN COME THROUGH
EDUCATION INTERACTION AND
CONVERSATION.
IN THE STATE OF JUDICIARY
JUDICIARY ADDRESS EARLIER THIS
YEAR OUR VERY OWN SUPREME COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE AND EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR
JUDGES AND UNCONSCIOUS.
BIAS TRAINING MANDATORY FOR ALL
COURT ADMINISTRATIVE EMPLOYEES.
AB TWO FOUR TWO SIX TO AMPLIFY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE'S WORK ON IMPLICIT
BIAS AND MANDATE THAT JUDGES AND
ATTORNEYS BE TRAINED EVERY THREE
YEARS AND COURT PERSONNEL EVERY
TWO YEARS.
TODAY WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS
LISA HOLDER EQUAL JUSTICE
SOCIETY LEGAL DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S
HEAR A WITNESS COULD GOOD
AFTERNOON.
AB GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS.
ARE LISA HOLDER CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY ALIEN Là LECTURE ON
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING.
AND I'M ADDRESSING YOU TODAY IN
MY CAPACITY AS AS LEGAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY.
AND OAKLAND BASS RACIAL JUSTICE
ADVOCACY GROUP.
SO EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY HAS
BEEN STUDYING IMPLICIT BIAS FOR
TWENTY YEARS SPECIFICALLY HOW IT
AFFECTS INDIVIDUAL DECISION
MAKING.
AND HOW IT AFFECTS INSTITUTIONS.
AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT
ALL PEOPLE HAVE IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND OUT WE ALSO CALL THAT
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
AND THOSE BIASES DEVELOPING
DEVELOP DURING THE COURSE OF A
LIFETIME TO EXPOSURE TO STEREO
TYPES USUALLY RACIAL AND GENDER
STEREOTYPES.
NO IMPLICIT BIAS INFLUENCES OUR
BELIEFS OUR ATTITUDES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR BEHAVIORS AND
OUR ACTIONS.
AND IT RUNS COUNTER. TO OUR
BELIEFS AND OUR VALUES OFTEN
WHICH IS WHAT SO INSIDIOUS ABOUT.
IMPLICIT BIAS -- AND AS FAR AS
INSTITUTIONS INDIVIDUAL IMPLICIT
BIAS IS REPLICATED IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS SO IT CAN END UP
HAVING.
A HUGE IMPACT INSTITUTIONALLY.
NOTE.
JUDGES ARE PEOPLE TOO SO THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT IMMUNE TO BIAS.
YET ASTONISHINGLY STUDIES SHOW
THAT 99% OF JUDGES SELF REPORT.
THAT THEIR JUDICIAL DECISIONS
ARE UNLIKELY TO BE AFFECTED BY
RACIAL AND GENDER BIAS COMPARED
TO THEIR COLLEAGUES.
SO EVEN THOUGH COMMITTEE JUDGES
EMBRACE THE CONCEPT OF IMPLICIT
BIAS WHEN IT COMES.
TO I'M.
THINKING ABOUT HOW IT AFFECTS
THEM IN THE COURT ROOM AS BENCH
OFFICERS.
THEY MAY NOT -- COMPLETELY
EXCEPT THAT IT IS HAVING AN
IMPACT ON THEIR COURTROOM AND ON
THEIR DECISION MAKING -- I'LL
JUST POINT TO A COUPLE OF QUICK
STUDIES COULD BECAUSE WHO ARE
COMING UP ON THE TWO MINUTE Là
GOT IT.
SO JUST WHAT ONE IMPACTFUL STUDY
IS THAT LOCALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO
BLACK DEFENDANTS ARE HELD IN PRE
TRIAL CUSTODY 62% LONGER THAN
WHITE DEFENDANTS.
AND BLACK DEFENDANTS RECEIVED
28% LONGER SENTENCES THAN WHITE
DEFENDANTS CONVICTED OF THE SAME
CRIMES.
SO POINT BEING COUNTED BY IS%
TRAINING IS A IS A PRACTICAL
TOOL FOR JUDGES AND THEY'RE ALL
THEIR OFFICERS WHO WORK WITH
THEM -- TO BECOME AWARE.
OF THEIR OWN BIASES AND TO
ACCEPT THEIR BIASES AND TO LEARN
TOOLS TO MANAGE AS A CRISIS.
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF COULD
COME FORWARD NAME AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
VERY CLEAR SHE HARM BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOES IT IS THEN -- HAVE LEGAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SPROUT
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAURIE
FURSTENFELD FROM THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
COR JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL PLUS THE
AUTHOR'S TIME ATTEND TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE MORE YOU W. IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SIDE OF ALL
RIGHT SEEING NON I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S PRACTICE LAW
FOR NUMBER YEARS I CAN ATTEST TO
THE GENDER BASED BIAS THAT --
CERTAINLY HAS EXISTED AND
PROBABLY STILL DOES I
FORTUNATELY BEEN RECOVERING FOR
NUMBER YEARS I HAVE BEEN IN THE
COURTROOM FOR A WHILE -- AND WE
KNOW WITH LITIGANTS THERE ARE
SIMILAR ISSUES OF MY ONLY
CONCERN.
HOW WE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS A COMPETENT TRAINING YOU'VE
GIVE TRIED TO IDENTIFY THAT?
BUT PUTTING A BUNCH OF LAWYERS
IN A ROOM.
A BUNCH OF JUDGES IN A ROOM IS
OFTEN A CHALLENGE TO GET THEM.
TO PAY ATTENTION I SAID THERE
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I AM
MARRIED TO A RETIRED JUDGE BUT
KNOWING THAT SO MANY.
THINK THAT THEY AS YOU MENTIONED
THEY SELF REPORT THERE'S NO BIAS
IN WHAT THEY DO.
IS THERE ANY WAY WE CAN BE
ASSURED WITH THESE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE.
RIGHT SO -- AS A AS AS SOMEONE
WHO'S ACTUALLY MERRY TUNE
ATTORNEY I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGE IT IS WHEN YOU'RE IN
THE ROOM WITH THEM -- THIS IS A
LITTLE LESS STILL LOOK AT THE
HISTORY BY TO THE NO LESS TRUE
OKAY -- THIS IS SO A I THINK THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT BY MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S SOME COMPETENCY
REQUIREMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
IDENTIFYING THE FOLKS THAT WILL
BE -- DEM OVERSEEING THE
TRAINING AND THERE IS AN
IMPLEMENTATION -- PERIOD OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THIS
DOESN'T KICK IN UNTIL THEN I
THINK IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY START
UNTIL TWENTY TWO SO IT ALLOWS
FOR THERE TO BE SOMETIME IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE WILL BE
NO TRAINING THAT WILL COMPLETELY
AROUND TO KEEP ANYTHING
PARTICULARLY AND PLUS AT OUR
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
IN I AM NOT GOING TO SUGGEST
THAT THIS BILL IS A SILVER
BULLET FOR THAT BUT IT CERTAINLY --
WILL WORK TO ADDRESS THE BIAS IN
WAYS THAT WILL HELP FOLKS
COUNTER ACTED IN BRACE CITIC
KNOWLEDGE IT SO THAT THEY CAN BE
BETTER.
AT THEIR JOBS IF IT IS ON THE
BENCH ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES
TO HAVING JUDICIAL DISCRETION
AND HOW IT'S WIELDED AND WIN --
TWO OFFICERS OF THE COURT AND
HOW THEY'RE INTERACTING -- WITH
DEFENDANTS PLAINTIFFS IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC -- I THINK IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO HAVE --
MONITORING AND INPUT FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL BECAUSE I THINK
THEY HAVE BEEN -- ACTUALLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS BILL -- AND HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO OFFER SOME GOOD COUNSEL IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU WOULD PUT
TOGETHER PARTICULAR --
CURRICULUM.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- THE BILL IS
NOT ABOUT SORT OF PLACING BLAME
WERE HAVING A GOTCHA.
WITH REGARDS TO JUDGES AND
LAWYERS BECAUSE IF YOU WERE TO
DO THAT AND PUT FOLKS ON DISPLAY
I THINK YOU WOULD SEE ON THE
EXACT OPPOSITE EFFECT OF WHAT WE
WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN WITH THIS
BILL.
BUT IT'S IN THE QUIET SPACES --
YOU KNOW IN THE OFFICES IN THE
TRAINING IN THE WORK -- WELL IN
THE THE THE WORK SPACES BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS WERE FOLKS WILL
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO HAVE HONEST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT M. C.
ELLIE IS ALSO A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO
GET YOUR CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND YOU'RE NOT PUTTING YOUR YOU
KNOW.
YOU KNOW TAKING A TEST AND
PUTTING THE RESULTS ON BLAST BUT
YOUR INTERNALIZING WHAT YEAR --
RECEIVING THROUGH THAT CONTINUE
A CONTINUING EDUCATION AND THEN
INTEGRATING AND PROCESSING IT IN
YOUR DAILY WORK THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION.
I'M SORRY CENTER BORCHERS.
FORGIVE ME AFFIRMED IF.
MAYBE THIS QUESTION WAS POSED
BEFORE ONES LIKE IT -- SO WE
ALREADY HAVE THE ELIMINATION OF
BIAS REQUIREMENT -- FOR THE M.
C. ELLIE [inaudible]
AND THIS IS NOT JUST A SUBSET OF
THAT THIS WOULD BE -- IN
ADDITIONAL ANA.
OUR REQUIREMENT WITHIN THAT.
TWENTY FIVE IS THAT IT.
IT'S A PART OF IT.
SO WE'RE NOT.
RIGHT IT'S A IT'S A SUBSET OF
THE ELIMINATION OF BIAS
REQUIREMENT CORRECT.
ALRIGHT BUT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
IN THE JUDICIARY -- YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE THE MANDATORY TRAINING --
LIKE I THINK ALL OF US HAVE TO
HAVE -- SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT.
REQUIREMENTS.
IS THAT CORRECT.
RIGHT RIGHT -- BUT IF YOU IS IT
I MEAN.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
BROUGHT THIS FORD IF YOU DIDN'T
THINK WAS IMPORTANT -- BUT THE
ELIMINATION OF OF A BIAS IN IN
THE CURRENT M. C. ELLIE --
ROSTER OF AVAILABLE CLASSES AND
WHATNOT.
IS THAT NOT.
SATISFACTORY.
OR THE JUDGE IS TO NOT HAVE TO
TAKE THE CAR THEY DON'T HAVE EM
SEALY REQUIREMENTS IT'S LAWYERS
WHO HAVE PLAYED LAWYERS LAWYERS
YEAH.
BUTFOR THOSE IN A SUPERVISORY
POSITION THEY STILL HAVE TO TAKE
THE ARE REQUIRED TRAINING EVERY
TWO YEARS.
IS THAT CORRECT SO THEY'RE
DIFFERENT.
KINDS OF TRAININGS THAT
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF PEOPLE TAKES
SO ATTORNEYS ARE DEALING THEY
HAVE THEY TAKE THEIR MCL EITHER
DIFFERENT TRAINING. FOR JUDGES
THIS IS INTEGRATING AND BOOK
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING INTO THE
HOURS THAT THERE ARE ANY
REQUIRED T TAKE SO.
UNLIKE US LEADS TAKES SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND WE TAKE ETHICS --
THERE BEEN SOME REPORTS THAT
SUGGEST THAT.
THAT MAYBE NOT THE BEST WAY TO
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION -- BUT
IF YOU'RE INTEGRATING IT INTO
HOW YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING YOUR
DAILY WORK AND THEN YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO SEE ITS IMPACT.
ACROSS ALL OF WHAT YOU DO RATHER
THAN COMING IN TO JUST TALK
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY THIS ONE
ISSUE -- BECAUSE AS WE DO NOW
IMPLICIT BIAS YOU KNOW IT
DOESN'T START AT NINE O'CLOCK IN
IN THAT FIVE OR IT DOESN'T START
WITH ONE CASE AND THEN AND WITH
ANOTHER.
BUT IT SHOULD BUT JUST OF THE
FINISH UP YOUR ATTORNEYS TAKE
MCLA AND REQUIRED.
JUDGES ARE THOSE IN A
SUPERVISORY POSITION OUR FIRST
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO TAKE -- A
SOME SORT OF TRAINING -- LIKE WE
DO FOR ALL THINGS YOU YOU JUST
SETS OF JUDGES WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO DO THAT AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
TAKING THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
SUPPORTS THIS SO THAT'S THERE
WAS TESTIMONY WE HAD.
TO GET HEARD PREVIOUSLY AS WELL
SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE THIS BILL WITH YOU AND
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
VERY GOOD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO FOUR TWO
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE PORGES.
PORCHES I'D ROSSUM RUSSELL I'D
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN UMBERG Y.
CASKEY.
I KELSEY I OR THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES ARE WE WILL.
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE -- AND
BEFORE WE GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM
LET'S CALL THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A SALUTE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER Y. KASKI.
OF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
FORGES I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN AMBERG WAY
CASKEY FIND WHAT CAUSED THE AYE.
ALL RIGHT THE SIX THIS YEAR WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF AND FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND FILE ITEM FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE HAS AB.
SEVEN FORTY NINE GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
FOR HEARING AB.
SEVEN FORTY NINE AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE IN YOUR STAFF IS DONE. TO
HELP IMPROVE THE BILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE CLARIFYING IT IN THE
IN THE NECESSARY NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE HIS AUTHORS AMENDMENT.
SO WHAT WE TRY TO SOLVE HERE AS
WE HAVE SEEN WITH THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT IN A LOT OF GREATER
AWARENESS OF THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT HAPPENS IN
ORGANIZATIONS BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. ONE OF THE ASPECTS OF
THAT THAT TO ME HAS BEEN
TROUBLING IN THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS HERE.
IS OFTENTIMES IN A SETTLEMENT.
AROUND A SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE
VICTIM.
IS WHO MAKES A CLAIM AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER MAKES CRIME AGAINST A
BAD ACTOR IS OFTEN THE ONE WHO
LEAVESYOU ORGANIZATION AND LEAD
TO ORGANIZATION.
WITH AN OBLIGATION.
WITH A NO HIRE AGREEMENT
OBLIGATED NEVER COME BACK TO
THAT ORGANIZATION NEVER TO BE
AVAILABLE TO BE HIRED AGAIN BY
THAT ORGANIZATION SUBSIDIARIES
OR OTHERS AND IT JUST SEEMS.
THAT WHAT WE ARE PERPETUATING
THAT CASES RETHINK.
THE VICTIM BECAUSE WE ARE
CLOSING OFF CAREERS CLOSE ENOUGH
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
OTHERS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
IT WOULD MAKE AS A MATTER OF
POLICY.
THE NO HIGHER PROVISIONS IN
THESE KINDS OF SETTLEMENTS.
NOT OPERATIVE NOW THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS A WITH THE IN THE THE
AMENDMENT ADDRESSES WE ARE STILL
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BAD
ACTORS CAN IN FACT BE SEPARATED
FROM.
THE FROM THE COMPANIES AND THE
THE THOSE THINGS THAT THAT
CERTAINLY CAN HAPPEN BUT THESE
NO WE HIRE PROVISIONS TEND TO BE
USED AS A MATTER OF COURSE.
AND AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY
WE THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE.
NO LONGER OPERATIVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTE TEACHER IF YOU WANT --
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANDREA ROW SO
I HAVE BEEN A LOT PRACTICE
YOU'RE UP FOR A DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT VICTIMS.
IN ELK GROVE AND I'M HERE JUST
TO ACCOMPANY MY FORMER.
CLIENT CARMEN FIELD WHO'S GOING
TO TELL YOU TODAY ABOUT HER
STORY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED IF YOU'D MOVE THE
MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
MY NAME IS CARMEN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CARMEN
FIELDS.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND MOVE THE
MICHAEL CLOSER BECAUSE I FEELING
YOU'VE GOT A SOFT VOICE.
OKAY.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU MY STORY
ABOUT HOW I LOST MY CAREER
BECAUSE I WAS FORCED TO RESIGN
AND AGREE TO A NO REHIRE BECAUSE
AS A CONDITION OF SETTLING MY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMING.
I STARTED WORKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL IN
APRIL OF TWO THOUSAND AND TEN IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
SHORTLY AFTER LETTER JOHNSON WAS
HIRED.
BY C. H. P..
HE BEGAN SEXUALLY HARASSING ME
AND OTHER FEMALE CO WORKERS IT
STARTED WITH HIM INSISTING THAT
I HIGH FIVE HIM THEN GRABBING MY
HAND WHEN I DECLINED.
I ASKED HIM TO STOP BUT HE WOULD
NOT.
I QUICKLY PER IT QUICKLY
PROGRESS TO HIM RUNNING HIS
FINGERS THROUGH MY HAIR.
I'M DOING MY HAIR WHEN I WHEN I
WOULD PUT IN A BUN.
AND FORCING HIS WAY ON TO
SITTING ON MY LAP.
THESE ACTIONS WERE WITNESSED BY
SEVERAL OTHER EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING SUPERVISORS I DEMANDED
THAT HE LEAVE ME ALONE I
FREQUENTLY COMPLAINED TO MY
COMMANDER.
WHO SAID SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO?
ABOUT THE HARASSMENT.
ON MARCH THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWELVE JIM.
JOHNSON ATTACKED ME DURING THE
INTO A PRIVATE TALK.
BY MY WRIST AND ATTEMPTING TO
KISS ME.
I'M PUSHING HIS BODY AGAINST
MINE.
AS I FOUGHT HIM OFF.
I REPORTED THIS CRIME TO THE
STAGE THREE MANAGERS INCLUDING
MY DIVISION CHIEF A UNIFORMED
POLICE OFFICER.
I DEMAND OF THE CHIEF PROTECT ME
FROM JOHNSON INVESTIGATING
INCIDENTS THE SHIFT RESPONSE WAS
TO LEAVE LENNY AND HIS MANAGER --
POSITION AND ADMINISTRATIVELY
TRANSFER YOU TO A LESS DESIRABLE
POSITION.
THE CHP EVENTUALLY ASSIGNED AN
INVESTIGATOR BUT THE CHP REFUSE
TO COMPLETE THEIR INVESTIGATION
AND I WAS LEFT WITH NO CHOICE
BUT TO FILE MY COMPLAINT WITH
THE EEOC.
ALTHOUGH JOHNSON HAD ADMITTED TO
SEXUALLY HARASSING SEVERAL
FEMALES UNDER HIS COMMAND WHILE
HE WAS A PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEE
THE SIEGE BE GRANTED HIM
PERMANENT CIVIL SERVICE STATUS
INFORMING HIM THAT HIS BEHAVIOR
QUOTE THAT THE STANDARDS AS EACH
BE EXPECTED OF ITS MANAGERS.
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC RECORDS
JOHNSON CONTINUES TO WORK FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MAKES 40% MORE THAN THE DAY WHEN
HE ATTACKED ME.
THE RETALIATION AGAINST ME
HOWEVER IS CONTINUED I WAS
DENIED PROMOTIONS BECAUSE I
FILED A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINT.
MY DAUGHTER WORKS FOR THE CITY
TREE AND HER SUPERVISOR BRAG
ABOUT NOT PROMOTING ME BECAUSE I
HAVE FILED A COMPLAINT.
THE CHP PRESSURED ME TO SETTLE
THE CASE.
AND THEY WERE ADAMANT THAT I BE
FORCED TO RESIGN.
I DID NOT WANT TO RESIGN.
I LOVE MY JOB AND THE FRIENDS I
HAVE.
THE MORE I PUSH AGAINST SETTLING
BY RESIGNING THE MORE THE GROSS
SO THEY GOT.
WITH ME AND MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
I WAS INFORMED THAT THEY INTEND
TO DEPOSE FAMILY.
FRIENDS GOING BACK TO MY
CHILDHOOD.
ALL I EVER WANTED WAS TO BE
PROTECTED FROM JONES.
AND TO SEE IF PEOPLE CLEAR THAT
WAS NEVER AN OPTION.
AS PART OF MY SETTLEMENT I WAS
FORCED TO AGREE TO A NO REHIRE
PROVISION MEANING I COULD NO
LONGER WORK FOR THE C. H. P. OR
ANY OF ITS DEPARTMENT AREAS OR
DIVISIONS.
THIS DESPITE HAVING OVER TWELVE
YEARS OF JOB EXPERIENCE SIX
YEARS OF EXEMPLARY PERFORMANCE
EVALUATIONS FROM C. H. P. AND A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE BEEN CONTACTED BY OTHER
SIEGE CAM PLOY USED TO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
HAVE TOLD ME THEY WILL NEVER
REPORT FROM FEAR WHAT THEY WILL
LOSE THEIR JOBS AS I DID.
IT IS UNFAIR THAT THE ADMITTED
HELP SEXUAL AROUSAL CONTINUES TO
WORK FOR THE STATE RECEIVING
PROMOTIONS AND RAISES WHILE I
PREVENTED FROM FURTHER
EMPLOYMENT WITH.
SIMPLY BECAUSE I ASKED TO BE
PROTECTED FROM HARASSMENT.
THIS IS NOT A HE SAID SHE SAID
SITUATION HE FREELY ADMITTED TO
ALL OF HIS ACTIONS.
AND HE DID NOT SEEM TO BE
EMBARRASSED OR ASHAMED.
REQUIRING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TO RESIGN AND AGREE
TO NEVER BE REHIRED IS THE
ULTIMATE FORM.
OF INSTITUTIONAL RETALIATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
I THINK YOU'RE.
PART OF THE REASON WE'RE HERE.
AT LEAST ON THIS BILL I IF YOU
COULD BE BRIEF REFLECTION AND
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JESSICA STANDER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL --
ESSENTIALLY THE QUESTION HERE IS
THAT THESE CLAUSES IT BECOMES
SURREPTITIOUSLY VERY COMMON AND
PRETTY STANDARD IN ALL
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS FOR
WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS.
AND THE QUESTION IS WHY DO
EMPLOYERS NEED TO INCLUDE THESE
<c.green>ROAD NO REHIRE CLAUSES AND ALL</c>
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
THEY SAY IT'S BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
THEM TO PROHIBIT AN EMPLOYEE
WHO'S WHO'S DONE SME HARM OR
ENGAGE IN SOME MISCONDUCT FROM
BEINGREHIRED HOWEVER THEY DON'T
NEED A NO REHIRE CLAUSE IN A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT TO TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT TASK.
THEY CAN SIMPLY REFUSED TO
REHIRE THEM AND HAVE A VALID
CLAIM FOR WIDE ARAMBULA
JUSTIFICATION FOR WHY THEY
FAILED TO REHIRE THEM OR DENIED
THEM RE HIGHER.
SO THE REASON WHY THEY ARE
IMPOSING ALL SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS ARE VIRTUALLY ALL IS
THAT ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO GET
AROUND OUR ANTI RETALIATION LAWS --
AND NOT RE HIRE SOMEONE SIMPLY
BECAUSE HERE SHE SPOKE OUT ABOUT
A WORKPLACE RIGHT VIOLATION WE
KNOW THAT EMPLOYERS DON'T
ACTUALLY WANT TO RE HIRE SOMEONE
WHO'S SPOKEN OUT ABOUT THEIR
RIGHTS.
AND THIS TYPE OF NO REHIRE
CLAUSE REALLY INSULATES THEM
FROM ANY TYPE OF RETALIATION
CLAIM FOR FAILING TO RE HIRE
SOMEONE WHO HAS FILED SUCH A
COMPLAINT OR CLAIM -- THESE
CAUSES REALLY HAVE NO LEGAL
PURPOSE BUT TO INSULATE
EMPLOYERS FROM LIABILITY -- FOR
RETALIATION FROM SOME AGAIN
SOMEONE WHO'S FILED A CLAIM AND
REALLY ARE UNNECESSARY AS THEY
WILL HAVE A VALID JUSTIFICATION
FOR DENYING NEW EMPLOYMENT
SOMEONE WHO IS ENGAGED IN SOME
KIND OF BAD CONDUCT.
OF FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
PROJECTS COSPONSORED HIS BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU PLEASE STEP
FORWARD NAME AN AFFILIATION.
VERY CLEAR SHE HARM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO PROUD
COSPONSORED THE SPELL STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT RICH WALLACE WITH THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU?
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LAURIE FURSTENFELD FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND IF WE COULD
MAKE WAY FOR THE TWO WITNESSES
THAT.
IF YOU WANTED.
pLIKE TO STAY OR SOME WOULD LIKE
TO STAY AS A CAPTION EXPERT WE
JUST NEED TO CHAIRS.
AND I JUST WANT TO CAUTION I MAY
HAVE TO EXCUSE MYSELF OF THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE A TIME CERTAIN TO
TRY.
TO THE PRESENT A COUPLE BILLS
BUT THEY'RE NOT READY YET SO IF
I DO LEAVE IT'S NOT FOR ANY
REASON OTHER THAN I'VE BEEN
CALLED TO TESTIFY.
ON THOSE OF THE BILL SO WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND START WITH THE
OPPOSITION GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER BROWN WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED. TO
THIS PROPOSAL -- AS THE PER --
PROPONENT SUGGESTED AS THE
AUTHOR PRESENTED THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS -- SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND PROTECT --
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE CLAIMED
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE AND
WE ACTUALLY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT HAVE OFFERED AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL
ADDRESSES THAT.
BUT THE CHALLENGE WITH THE BILL
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED AS IT
INCLUDES BOTH THE VICTIM OF
HARASSMENT AND GIVES THAT PART --
THAT INDIVIDUAL PROTECTION AS
WELL AS THE HARASSER THEMSELVES
LAST YEAR WE SPONSORED AB
SIXTEEN OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN WHO ADDRESSED
INFORMATION WITH REGARDS TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BECAUSE AS WE
HAVE SEEN WITH REGARDS TO THE
HARASSERS.
IS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL ONCE THEY
ARE.
WIMPS WE INVESTIGATE AND WE
ALLEGE OR FIND THAT THERE HAS
BEEN HARASSMENT BY THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT INDIVIDUAL FILE
DEFAMATION CLAIMS AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER FOR SUGGESTING THEY
ENGAGED IN HARASSMENT.
I'M ALSO FILED DEFAMATION CLAIMS
AGAINST THE ACTUAL EMPLOYEE WHO
ALLEGE HARASSMENT AS WELL AS
WITNESSES WHO ENGAGED AND
PARTICIPATED IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
RIGHT NOW UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
THE DEFINITION OF AN AGGRIEVED
EMPLOYEE IS ANYBODY WHO HAS
FILED A CLAIM AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER THAT INCLUDES THE
HARASSER WHO FILES A CLAIM
AGAINST US FOR DEFAMATION WHEN
WE THE LEISURE FOUND THAT
THEY'VE ENGAGED IN HARASSMENT SO
WE HAVE A CONCERN.
THAT YES THIS MAY HELP PROTECT
THOSE VICTIMS OF HARASSMENT WE
AGREE WITH THAT -- BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A CONCERN THAT IT ALSO
PROTECTS THE BAD ACTORS WHO HAVE
FILED -- CLAIMS AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER NOW I ALSO AGREE WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE PROPONENTS
THAT THERE'S NOTHING IN LAW THAT
REQUIRES US TO REHIRE ANY
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S TRUE. FOR THE
VICTIM OF HARASSMENT AND THAT'S
TRUE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
ENGAGED IN HARASSMENT HOWEVER
WHAT THIS DOES IS CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC IN THE CAUSE OF ACTION
AGAINST US WE NOW HAVE.
TO ATTENTION TO DEFEND A
RETALIATION CLAIM WHERE'S BEFORE
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT A
BREACH OF CONTRACT WITH AN
AGREEMENT AND THESE ARE NOT TAKE
IT OR LEAVE -- WHERE THE
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL SO AGAIN --
IT ADDS TO LITIGATION AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT IF SOMEBODY'S
GOING TO FILE A DEFAMATION CLAIM
AGAINST A VICTIM OF HARASSMENT
ALLEGE THAT THEIR DEFAMING THEM.
IT'S NOT THAT FAR STRETCH TO
THINK THAT THAT SAME INDIVIDUAL
FILE A RETALIATION CLAIM AGAINST
AN EMPLOYER IF THERE'S NOT A NO
REHIRE CLAUSE IN THAT SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE POST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MINUTES PLEASE IT'S RETURN
MEMBERS MIGHT PULL OUT ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAW
COUNCIL AND THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE FED
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR -- I THOUGHT THAT THE
ANALYSIS DID A GOOD JOB GOING
THROUGH THE INTRICACIES OF THE
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP AT ISSUE
HERE I THINK THE PROBLEM WITH
THE BILL IS ADDED OVER PLEADS
THE CASE.
THAT APPLIES TO EVERY FORM OF
DISPUTE.
ANY COMPLAINT OF AN EMPLOYMENT
NATURE FILED BY THE EMPLOYEE.
APPLIES WHETHER THE EMPLOYEE IS
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL OR NOT
THESE ARE USUALLY HIGHLY
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENTS AND THIS
WOULD OVERRIDE THE DECISION OF
OF BOTH SIDES COUNSEL TO ENGAGE
IN THE AGREEMENT -- IT IS NICE
TO CLARIFY THAT NOTHING IN THE
BILL REQUIRES RE HIGHER BUT AS
MS BARRERA NOTED IT SHIFTS THE
DEBATE FOR WHY WE DIDN'T RE HIRE
THE EMPLOYEE OFTEN THIS IS.
FAIRLY NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT
WHERE BOTH SIDES WANT TO END THE
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP THERE'S
AGREEMENT NOT TO REHIRE.
INTERESTING THAT THE EXAMPLES
THAT WE WERE GIVEN -- SO FAR I'M
SURE THEY HAPPEN IN THE PRIVATESECTOR BUT THEY'RE PREDOMINATELY
PUBLIC SECTOR -- EXAMPLES SO WE
THINK THAT THE BILL IS OVER
BROAD WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO SEE IF
WE CAN NARROW IT TO THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SITUATIONS THE
EGREGIOUS ONES LIKE WE HEARD
FROM THE WITNESS.
AND NOT OVER PLEAD THE BILL AND
HAVE IT APPLY TO BROADLY TO ALL
DISPUTES.
ALL AGREEMENTS AND WHETHER
REPRESENTED OR NOT FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS THAT --
OUR STEAM TO CHAIR WOMAN I HAS
LEFT FOR ANOTHER -- PRESENTATION
SO WITH THE GAVEL IS PASSED ON
TO ME AND WE MAY VERY WELL FIND
OURSELVES SITUATION WHERE THE
GAVEL COULD BE PASSED TO
SOMEBODY ELSE -- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT -- WE'VE
HAD -- THE TO UPON
REPRESENTATIVES SPEAKING NOW
WILL OPEN UP -- TO OTHER FOLKS
IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND AND
YOUR VERY BRIEF A STATEMENT OF
OPPOSITION THANK YOU OF SEAN
LEWIS REPORTS ABOUT THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF IN A BUSINESS AND
ARE TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS VERY CONCERNED.
WITH THE INCREASED THREAT OF
LITIGATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
YOU.
JR MEMBERS DON'T GIVEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL CORBITT
REPRESENTING THE C. SACK ACCESS
INSURANCE AT FORTY WHICH
REPRESENTS MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER MEMBER THE
PUBLIC WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK -- TO
THE DAIS [inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I FIRST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THINK THE WITNESS WHO
COURAGEOUSLY SHARED HER STORY.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S STILL IN
THE ROOM BUT SHE MAKES A STRONG
CASE.
FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS IS
ANYONE OF THAT CH P. OFFICER WHO
ENGAGED IN THE HARASSMENT IS
STILL EMPLOYED BY THE CHP IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT HE IS YES
YOU ARE HE IS THAT.
HE IS STILL EMPLOYED -- AS A
MATTER OF FACT HE WAS THE MOTIVE
SEVERAL TIMES BUT HE STILL
CONTINUES TO BE EMPLOYED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I WAS JUST CURIOUS IN
IT'S ANOTHER ELEMENT OF THE
INJUSTICE THAT SHE DESCRIBED.
THE QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR --
IN I SUPPORT THE OBJECTIVES OF
THIS LEGISLATION HAVING
REPRESENTED PLAINTIFFS IN
EMPLOYMENT CASES.
SOMETIMES A PLAINTIFF WHO HAS
BEEN TERMINATED.
DOES NOT WANT TO RETURN TO THE
WORKPLACE.
WHERE THE DISCRIMINATION
HAPPENED?
IN.
IT CAN BE A FACTOR IN IN
NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT TO INCLUDE
A PROVISION.
OF NOT RETURNING. TO LEVERAGE
MORE MONETARY COMPENSATION. TO
THE COMPLAINING PLAINTIFF WITH
THIS BILL PROHIBIT AND
NEGOTIATED.
ARMS LENGTH AGREEMENT NOT A
MANDATORY.
NOT COMING FROM THE EMPLOYER
THAT YOU -- HAVE TO SUBMIT YOUR
RESIGNATION BUT WITH THIS
PREVENT.
THE COMPLAINING PLAINTIFF FROM
NEGOTIATING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO RETURN.
THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON THE TABLE.
THE EMPLOYER DOESN'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO OFFER THEM
THAT THE COURT MAY BE IS.
WHAT WOULD REQUIRE REEMPLOYMENT?
BUT THE PLAINTIFF MAY BE ABLE TO
SECURE.
SOMETHING THAT IS OF GREATER
INTEREST TO THEM IT WOULD AND
WE'RE TRYING NOT NECESSARILY
TAKE LEVERAGE AWAY FROM THE
PLAINTIFFS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THESE
NO REHIRE PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN
USED.
THERE USED MORE.
AGREE JUST LEAVE THAN
BENEFICIALLY IN THAT STANDPOINT
SO TO MISTER BELOW ITS POINT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE SORT OF
OVER SUBSCRIBING THIS AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PATTERN OF HOW THESE
THINGS HAVE COME INTO SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS AND THEY'RE OFTEN
PITCH SAID.
I'VE BEEN ON DIRTY ON THE INSIDE
ON THESE ON THESE QUESTIONS
THEY'RE SORT OF PITCHED AS THIS
IS A STANDARD FORM AGREEMENT WE
WANT.
TO JUST PUT YOU IN THE SAME
POSITION AS EVERYONE ELSE.
THERE'S NOT ALWAYS A LOT OF
CHOICE GIVEN.
THAT'S WILL WORKING AGAINST I AM
SENSITIVE TO POTENTIALLY.
I AM POTENTIALLY TRYING TO GO A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER THEN MAYBE WE
NEEDED TO AYE I DON'T WANT TO GO
OVERLY BROAD ON THIS.
BUT I WORRY THAT IF WE RESTRICT
THIS A LOT WE'RE GONNA BE
FACILITATING THE KINDS OF
AGREEMENTS.
AND RELATIONSHIPS THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPING IN THE PAST AND
AGAIN THESE ARE VICTIMS REALLY
BEING RE VICTIMIZED.
THAT IF THE VICTIM WANTS TO
LEAVE AND GETS A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THERE'S NO OBLIGATION
FOR THEM TO COME BACK WE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT SITUATION BUT
REALIZE.
TOO THAT WITH A LOT OF COMPANIES
WITH A LOT OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
THAT ARE MENTIONED.
THERE ARE A MYRIAD OF RELATED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THEN OFF
THE TABLE FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL
THAT THEY MAY NOT REALIZE.
YES ITS COMPLEXITIES EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIPS ARE VERY COMPLEX
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO JUST TAKE
A A TOOL OFF THE TABLE THAT HAS
BEEN MISUSED MORE THAN IT'S BEEN
BENEFICIALLY USE.
AND RE BALANCE THAT PLAYING
FIELD A LITTLE BIT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT DID EITHER OF
YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT TO THEM
I JUST WANTED AND WE WERE
GENERALLY REPRESENT LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO GO SHEET THE
TERMS THIS ONE INCLUDED OF THESE
THEIR SETTLEMENT.
AGREEMENTS AND ARE NOT ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE ANY KIND OF HIGHER
COMPENSATION.
FOR THIS PROVISION BUT RATHER
REQUIRED TO TAKE IT ON A TAKE IT
OR LEAVE IT BASIS -- AND OFTEN
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOME POINTED
OUT DON'T ALWAYS REALIZE THE
BREADTH OF THE AND THE SCOPE OF
THESE PROVISIONS AND BELIEVE IT
MAY JUST BE FOR THAT ONE
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER AND THEN
COME TO FIND LATER WHEN THEY
APPLY FOR A JOB AT WHAT SEEMS TO
BE A SEPARATE.
ENTITY THAT THEY'RE NOW BARRED
FROM EMPLOYMENT IN A VARIETY OF
OTHER CONTACTS THAT THEY HADN'T
EVEN UNDERSTOOD WOULD BE THE
CASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S HELPFUL MEN
WITH RESPECT TO LEAST ONE A
CONCERNS OF OF THE OPPONENTS --
NOTHING THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE
TERMINATION OF A BAD ACTOR WHO'S
BEEN THE PERPETRATOR OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE IS THAT CORRECT
THAT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
NOW THE TERMS OF THIS WOULD
STILL APPLY.
BY COMPANIES HAVE THE ABILITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THEY'RE
AWARE OF THE POOLS AND AND GIVEN
THEM THE STATE OF EMPLOYMENT LAW.
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES ARE OFTEN
VERY HIGHLY THAT SO THEY ARE
ABLE TO KEEP A RECORD THEY THEY
KNOW WHO THEY SHOULD NOT BE RE
HIRING.
AND SO THE THE COMMENT ABOUT.
CREATING AND I DON'T THINK THIS
IS GOING TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION THAT THAT THE FEARS
RUN BECAUSE THAT RETALIATORY SO
SOMEBODY HAS BEEN SEPARATED
SOMEBODY WHO'S A BAD ACTOR HAS
BEEN SEPARATE FROM COMPANY.
AND THEN APPLIES BACK THAT THE
NEXUS TO THE ORIGINAL CLAIM THAT
GOT THEM DISMISSED OR NEGOTIATED
DISMISSAL OR OR LEFT THE COMPANY
IS BROKEN ONCE THEY'RE NO LONGER
HIGHER.
SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO MAKE A RETALIATION CLAIM FOR
THE FACT OF THEM NOT GETTING
HIRED WHEN THE COMPANY IS.
FREE TO JUST SAY YOU'RE NOT
WE'RE NT GOING TO HIRE YOU.
AND A LOT OF TIMES WHEN WHEN
COMMITTEES ASIDE NOT TO HIRE
SOMEBODY OR PUBLIC AGENCIES IS
THE CASE.
THEY'RE NOT EXPLAINING MUCH THEY
DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN MUCH WE'RE
NOT ASKING THEM TO EXPLAIN MUCH.
BUT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING THEM TO BE HEARD BACK
YET SO I THINK THE HIRING
ORGANIZATION BE A PUBLIC AGENCY
A PRIVATE AGENCY.
HAS PLENTY OF TOOLS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT BRINGING A BAD
ACTOR BACK INTO THE K. INTO
THEIR FOLD WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
WHAT WE DO NOT WANT AND I WOULD
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT ON BALANCE HOW THESE CLAUSES
HAVE BEEN USED I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS JUST TAKE THEM
OFF THE TABLE AS A TOOL AND THEN
LET THE ORGANIZATIONS CONTINUE
TO FUNCTION THE WAY THAT THEY
FUNCTION AND MANAGE THEIR
EMPLOYEES RIGHT NOW IF THAT
FORMER BAD ACTOR EMPLOYEE. SIX
RE HIGHER IN IS DENIED AND TRIES
TO FILE A CASE RETALIATION
NOTHING PREVENTS THE EMPLOYER
FROM SHARING THE EVIDENCE.
OF WHY THEY WERE LET GO TO BEGIN
WITH.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER A NUMBER THE COMMITTEE.
WE'RE KIND OF SPARSE AT THIS
POINT -- LECTURE WAS GOING TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE WITH HIS HIS
COMMENTS JUST JUST FOR CLARITY.
SO IN INDIVIDUAL ON LEAVES.
AS PART OF A SETTLEMENT AND TRY
STERN RE HIGHER AND FOR THE
REASONS THAT HE JUST MENTIONED.
IS NOT HIRED -- IS THAT
DISCOVERABLE INFORMATION.
THE THE PAST HISTORY
[inaudible] EIGHT POTENTIALLY
YEAH A SORT OF DEPENDS ON WHO
THE PARTS OF THEIR GOING BACK TO
THE SAME COMPANY -- YEAH I WOULD
I WOULD THINK IF IF THEY'RE
TRYING TO MAKE A DISCRIMINATION
CLAIM.
BUT IN TALKING TO THE EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS MOST OF THEM IT'S IT'S
NOT A CLAIM THAT LAWYERS WOULD
NECESSARILY TAKE ON BECAUSE
AGAIN THE BE MAKING A
DISCRIMINATION CLAIM FOR THE
CURRENT NON HIGHER DECISION.
THAT REALLY HAS NOTHING TO DO.
THE DEAD HAS BROKEN THEIR NEXUS
WITH THE THE REASON FOR THE
TERMINATION.
SO THE EMPLOYER COULD SAY.
YOU ARREST OR ANY INTERNALLY
MAKE THAT.
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION THIS IS
NOT THE KIND OF A CANDIDATE WE
WANT TO HIRE AND THEY HAVE THOSE
RECORDS THEY COULD BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
SO THEN IF THAT POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEE DID SU.
THEN GET THERE THROUGH THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS THEY MAY THEN
GET ACCESS TO THEIR PRIOR
EMPLOYMENT RECORD.
AS LONG AS THE COMPANY HAD
DOCUMENTED THE REASON FOR THAT
DETERMINATION AND WHAT HAD
HAPPENED IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE I
WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BOLSTER.
YOUR CRIMINALS HIGHER SO --
THERE WERE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE AGREED TO YES OUT.
WAS THIS A RECENT.
EVENT IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN THAT NOTE THE IS IS IT WAS
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS OR WITHIN
THE LAST WEEK IN WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE GUY.
SO I'M LOOKING AT ONE OF THEM
WHICH SUBSECTION BEING.
NOTHING EN SUBDIVISION SHALL
REQUIRE AN EMPLOYER TO CONTINUE
TO EMPLOYER HIGHER PERSON WHEN
THERE'S A LEGITIMATE NON
DISCRIMINATORY.
OR NON RETALIATORY REASON FOR
TERMINATING THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP.
OR REFUSING TO RE HIRE THE
PERSON CORRECT AND WE AND WE I
THINK THAT THE THAT THE BILL.
THAT THAT'S A CLARIFICATION I
THINK THE WE WERE SILENT ON THAT
I DON'T THINK WE SET UP ANY
OBLIGATION TO REHIRE OR
INTERFERE WITH THAT RELATIONSHIP
BUT BASED ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED.
WE'RE PUTTING THESE PROVISIONS
AND HAVING WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
INTERRUPT THE ABILITY THE
COMPANY TO NOT REHIRE. FOR THE
THEY COULD ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH AS AN EMPLOYEE
ESPECIALLY THE BAD ACTOR TO
SEPARATE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND NOTHING IN THE SUBDIVISION
NOTHING IN THIS SHOP PRECLUDE
THE EMPLOYER AND AGREE PERSON
FROM MAKING AN AGREEMENT TO END
A CURRENT EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP.
CORRECT AND AND THAT WAS BECAUSE
WE WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
WAS THAT IF THERE IS A BAD ACTOR
AND THAT ORGANIZATION WANTS TO
TERMINATE THAT BAD ACTOR THAT
COULD BE DONE THROUGH A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IF YOU WELL
THEY THEY COULD AGREE. TO PART
WAYS WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT STILL COULD HAPPEN OR NOT
INTERFERE WITH THAT RELATIONSHIP
WE'RE REALLY MORE FOCUSED ON THE
REHIRE PROVISION TO OF THE NO
REHIRE PROVISION.
THAT WOULD NOT BE EVEN FOR A BAD
ACTOR.
THAT WOULD NOT BE A PART OF
THEIR SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT BUT
THEY COULD CERTAINLY SETTLE THEY
COULD CERTAINLY.
MOVE THAT EMPLOYEE OUT AND THEN
THERE'S NO OBLIGATION TO BRING
THEM BACK AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
THEY JUST WANT TO MAKE MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THE FOLKS WHO SPOKE
IN OPPOSITION -- ARE FULLY AWARE
OF THESE AMENDMENTS.
AND STILL MAINTAIN OPPOSITION
POSITIONS BUT SPEAK FOR THEM BUT
OBVIOUSLY I'M LOOKING AT NODDING
HEADS AT THE MOMENT YEAH OKAY --
ANY OTHER FINAL.
ALL RIGHT -- DO WE HAVE
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
IN THE IS THIS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WERE CISCO NEXT.
HAS AMENDED TO FLOOR.
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY AS CENTER
DRAWS A TO PASS A MINUTE TO THE
FLOOR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVEN
FOUR NINE TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR JACKSON
GORGEOUS.
NO BORDERS NO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN UMBERG WHITE
HOUSE E.. THREE ONE THREE TO ONE
I WILL KEEP THIS -- OPEN.
THANK YOU SENATORS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MOVING ON TO ARE WE ON A. B. TEN
NINE TO JOIN JONES SAWYER.
THE WOMAN REASON WAS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU KNOW IF ANYONE'S HERE
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
NUMBER -- EIGHT AB ELEVEN OH SIX
SMITH -- ARE YOU ARE PREPARED
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
NO OPPOSITION.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND WELCOME TO OUR
NEWEST CALLING WHO I HAVEN'T HAD
THE PLEASURE FORMALLY MEETING IT
WAS NICE TO SEE YOU.
ARE THE HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SERVING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HOMEOWNERS INTENT
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE ENHANCED
HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WAS ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO COMBAT THE EFFECTS OF
THE MORTGAGE CRISIS.
IT HAS ALLOW THE COUNTY TO
EXPAND SERVICES TO HOMEOWNERS
THAT INCLUDE COUNSELING SUPPORT
TENANT RELOCATION SERVICES AND
LOAN MODIFICATION ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK
OF THE PROGRAM BY EXTENDING THE
CURRENT SUNSET DATE.
TWO TWENTY THIRTY AND HELP THE
COUNTY KEEP ITS RESIDENTS IN
HOUSING.
WITH ME TODAY IS BRIAN STEIGER
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS --
BRIAN STICKER ON THE ON BEHALF
OF THE LATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AB ELEVEN OH SIX WOULD SIMPLY
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE ON THE
ENHANCE PORTION OF A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THE HOMEOWNER
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM.
THIS UNIQUE PROGRAM HELPS
DISTRESSED HOMEOWNERS SAVE THEIR
HOMES FROM FORECLOSURE AND
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS FROM BECOMING
VICTIMS OF FRAUDULENT FOR CLOSER
CONSULTANTS.
ALTHOUGH THE RATE OF
FORECLOSURES HAS SOMEWHAT LEVELS
SINCE THE HEIGHT OF FORECLOSURE
CRISIS WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
HOMEOWNERS EACH MONTH WE SEE
FORECLOSURE NOTICES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
MAYBE IT'S HOMEOWNERS BECOME
TARGETED BY FRAUDULENT
FORECLOSURE CONSULTANT TO
ADVERTISE SOLUTIONS IN ECHANGE
FOR COSTLY SERVICES THAT ARE
NEVER ACTUALLY RENDERED.
THIS INCLUDES FALSE CLAIMS OF
GUARANTEES THAT THE CONSOLE TO
CONSTRUCT THE FORECLOSURE
PROMISES OF A NEW LOAN OR LOAN
MODIFICATION OR THAT AN INVESTOR
WILL BY THE HOME.
AB -- ELEVEN SIX WOULD EXTEND TO
TWENTY THIRTY THE PORTION OF
THIS PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS THE
COUNTY TO COLLECT A SEVEN DOLLAR
RECORDING FEE. FOUR NOTICES OF
DEFAULT AND USE THOSE FEES
STROLLER HOMEOWNERS AT THEIR
HOME IS IN FORECLOSURE.
EXPLAIN THE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE LAW AND
ENABLE THE COUNTY TO PROVIDE
FREE AND TRUSTED SERVICES SUCH
AS MORTGAGE COUNSELING.
SINCE TWO TWENTY ELEVEN THIS --
LA COUNTY HAS RECEIVED OVER
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED FOUGHT
COMPLAINTS THAT THIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE TO OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN RESTITUTION
TO HOMEOWNERS.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
WRAPPING THIS PROGRAM UNTIL
OWSLEY COUNTY TO CONTINUE THIS
IMPORTANT WORK AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC -- WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE I DO NOT BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY WRITTEN OPPOSITION BUT
ANY -- PERSONS HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
TO THIS ITEM SEEING.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC.
SAYING THEN BRING IT BACK -- TO
THE DAIS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT ROBUST DEBATE.
THERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT -- SO THE MOTION IS BY
SENATOR -- MINING -- AS YOU DO
PASS ON TO THE SENATE FLOOR --
CAN BE SURGERY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB ELEVEN
OH SIX JACKSON BORDERS HI OR
DECIDE TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONEY.
MONEY AYE STERN UMBERG Y. CASKEY.
FOUR ZERO FOUR TWO ZERO WE WILL
KEEP -- THE BILL ON A CALL
[inaudible]
AND SEE DO WE HAVE.
GOING BACK TO TEN NINETY TWO WE
HAVE A JONES SAWYER HERE.
NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB.
FOR SIXTEEN FIFTEEN ARE WE
FOLLOWING THIS THIS LINE.
OKAY SO WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B..
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- FRIEDMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
A LOT OF FACE TIME TODAY
SERIOUSLY VERY MUCH -- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THIS BILL --
FISA THAT WHEN IF THE COMMUNITY
HAS AN IMPROVED COMMUNITY PLAN
AT THE COMMUNITY HAS GONE
THROUGH THEIR SEEK REVIEW
THEY'VE DONE THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
OUTREACH THEY'VE ADOPTED A
COMMUNITY PLAN.
THAT ANY PROJECT THAT IS DEEMED
COMPLETE.
WHEN IT SUBMITTED AND ALL OF
THEIR APPLICATION IS DONE AND
THE THE -- APPLICATION IS DEEMED
COMPLETE THEY WILL BE ALLOWED TO
PROCEED IN THE EVENT THAT THERE
IS A CIVIL LAWSUIT OVER THE
COMMUNITY PLAN AND THE JUDGE
ISSUES A STAY ON THE COMMUNITY
PLAN.
THIS IS REALLY THE STOP WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS OCCASIONALLY WERE
PROJECTS GET CAUGHT IN THE
MIDDLE.
THE DEVELOPER HAS OPERATED UNDER
THE UPDATED GENERAL PLAN IT WAS
A PLAN THAT WAS LEGALLY ADOPTED
AT THE TIME WHEN THEY DID ALL OF
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE WHEN THEY
CREATED THEIR PROJECT WHEN THEY
DID THE COMMUNITY OUT REACH WHEN
THEY DID THEIR OWN SEQUEL IF IF
IF SO YOU.
KNOW IF NECESSARY THEY'VE DONE
ALL F THAT LEE WORK AND I'M IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING THEIR
APPROVALS THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE.
TO SUFFER BECAUSE SOMEONE SUED
NOT OVER THEIR OWN PROJECT BUT
OVER THE ENTIRE GENERAL PLAN --
RIGHT NOW THE LAW IS SILENT AND
PROUD BECAUSE THE LAW IS SILENT
ABOUT THIS WHAT HAPPENS IS
COMMUNITY PLANNING DEPARTMENTS
KINDA GET NERVOUS AND THEY SAY
WELL WE'VE GOT THIS LAWSUIT OVER
A GENERAL PLAN WE'RE JUST NOT
GOING TO LET YOU BUILD EVEN
THOUGH MAYBE YOU'VE HAD YOUR
APPROVALS.
OR YOUR YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR
ENTITLEMENTS AND SO THAT
DEVELOPER AND SAID JUST GETTING
KIND OF CAUGHT IN THE CROSSFIRE.
WE WANT TO CLARIFY THE LAW THAT
THAT PROJECT CAN STILL GO
FORWARD WHILE THE LAWSUITS BEING
DISPENSED WITH ABOUT THE GENERAL
PLAN.
THAT'S THE GIST OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO I DO HAVE SOMEONE
WITH ME HERE TODAY -- YOU CAN
INTRODUCE HERSELF WELCOME IF YOU
COULD INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
PLEASE KEEP IN TWO MINUTES OR
LESS THANK YOU DEFINITELY
SILVIUS ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI.
I AM WE'D LIKE TO THINK I SIMPLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER WORK AS
WELL AS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
FOR THE CITY WE HAVE.
AMERICA CITY HAS COMMITTED TO
UPDATING ALL OF THE CITY'S
THIRTY FIVE COMMUNITY PLANS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE'VE
COMMITTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
FUND THESE EFFORTS.
AND WE HAVE HIRED ALMOST SEVENTY
STAFF IN THE LAST FEW YEARS --
AS PART OF THIS UPDATE PROCESS
THE CITY IS WORKING TO ALIGN THE
LAND USE POLICIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY PLANS WITH STATE AND
LOCAL GOALS THAT SUPPORT BOTH
INCREASED HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
OF ITS OWN WE BELIEVE AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SAID
THAT THIS BILL REMOVES AMBIGUITY
HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PROPERTY OWNERS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BETTER UNDERSTAND.
HOW THESE UPDATED LAND USE PLANS
MAY BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE EVENT
OF A CHALLENGE SO WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION?
THANK YOU THIS TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC -- IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
YOUR AFFILIATION AND STATE YOUR
POSITION GOOD AFTERNOON YELEY
COVERAGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THIS CLEAR
PATH THAT THIS BILL WILL CREATE.
FOR HOUSING THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED IN A TIME OF
DESPERATE HOUSING NEED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WHERE A TOP OF THE HAVE THE CITY
OF SAN DIGO IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBER THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO COMMENT THIS
TO BE THAT OPPORTUNITY -- SEEING
NONE ANY -- FOLKS IN OPPOSITION
THIS WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY --
FOR YOU TO PRESENT I AT THE DESK
IF YOU WISH IF YOU'RE PRINCIPLE
OP OPPONENT.
YOUR TWITTER ALL RIGHTS -- IT
WILL BEFORE WE GET TO TWEETERS
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TWEETERS ARE UP.
YES THANK YOU BRING AND ALSO HAS
HERE COME
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENSION
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO STAY AFTER THE
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO IT NO OTHER MEMBER THE
PUBLIC BRING IT TO TO THE DAIS --
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
WHEN I MOVE IT I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS -- ITEM I
KNOW WE'VE GOT SECOND MANY
SITUATIONS SIMILAR TO THIS IN
LONG BEACH AND THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THIS VERY CLEAR FOR US
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUST A QUICK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF I MAY UM SO THIS
PERTAINS TO COMMUNITY PLANS.
I THINK DID I HEAR YOU SAY
GENERAL PLANS EARLIER.
THIS WOULD BE -- FOR COMMUNITY
PLANS ARE NOT THE NOT THE
GENERAL FEDERAL PLAN FEDERAL
PLANS AS WELL.
PLANS NOT THE GENERAL PLAN
ALRIGHT SO THE LEVEL OF ITS.
OF DETAIL IN COMMITTEE PLANS --
IT IS NOT AS SPECIFIC AS AS
WOULD BE A SPECIFIC PLAN
ACTUALLY SOMETIMES THE COMMUNITY
PLANS IS EVEN MORE GRANULAR AND
A LARGE CITY LIKE LOS ANGELES
THEIR GENERAL PLAN IS BUILT ON
THIS YEAR IS NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY PLANS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
IN A CALL OVER A COURSE OF YEARS
TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT AREAS
THEY WANT TO UPS OWN WHERE THEY
WANT TO DOWN ZONE WHERE THEY
WANT THEIR DEVELOPMENT TO BE.
A CITY OF GLENDALE SPENT WHEN I
WAS ON THE COUNCIL MANY YEARS
DEVELOPING THEIR SOUTHLAND A
COMMUNITY PLAN WHICH IS A VERY
IN DEPTH DOCUMENT THAT THINK
IT'S FOLDED INTO THE GENERAL
PLAN BUT IT'S THE PLAN THAT
GOVERNS THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THE REASON WHY WE'VE OR WERE
TAKING THIS APPROACH IS BECAUSE
IT'S THE GENERAL PLAN LEVEL
THAT'S BEING SUED I'M IN THE
CITIES ARE NOT SUING OVER THE
ENTIRE GENERAL PLAN.
THERE ARE.
THERE'S TRYING TO PREVENT THE
CITY FROM A DOCK FROM ADOPTING
THESE THESE COMMUNITY PLANS.
OKAY SO THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
CHALLENGING THE COMMUNITY PLAN
RIGHT THE GENERAL PLAN THE
CORRECT THE COMMUNITY PLANS AND
GET THE GENERAL PLAN REMAINS IN
EXISTENCE IT'S SORT OF UPDATED
THROUGH THESE COMMUNITY PLANS.
SO THE GENERAL PLAN IS JUST THIS
DOCUMENT KIND OF LIKE OUR
CONSTITUTION WE DON'T DO THE
CONSTITUTION WE MAY DO AN
AMENDMENT THE LIKE AN AMENDMENT
SO THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE AND THE
FINAL IN THEIR LAWSUITS OVER.
AND IF -- IF CENTER DRAWS -- HAD
NOT -- MADE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
ITEM I CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT -- LET'S
SEE -- SO THE MOTION IS TO TO DO
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR --
COMMITTEE SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN JACKSON.
GORGEOUS HI WE'RE JUST I TO
RUSSELL TO WRESTLE AYE GONZALEZ.
CONSOLES I JONES MONNING STERN
UMBERG Y. CASKEY.
HEY WE WILL BE HERE THE BILL ON
CALL -- WHO WE THINK IS NEXT
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW.
HIGHLIGHTED -- WHICH ONES HERE.
WELL I DON'T WITH LOW WILD AB
THIRTY FOUR TWELVE OKAY WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW HERE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWELVE
THIS IS AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
[inaudible] FIVE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS.
HELPS ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TYPE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE TOURNEY
GENERAL TO APPROVE THE SALE OF
SUCH NONPROFIT COLLEGES -- JOEL
DIED AND WE YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THE BILL DIED IN THEIR LITTLE
NOISE BACK DID YOU WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING I DID GET A JOB THIS IS --
IT FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
HELP ENSURE THE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SUCH
TRANSACTIONS PROTECTED A
STUDENTS AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS
ALIKE WITH RESPECT.
AS FOR AYE VOTE.
ANY OTHER MEMBER OF YOUR TEAM
WISHING TO USE THIS TIME AS OUR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALLOCATE
DONNIE -- REPRESENTING THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION -- TO BE
BRIEF -- THIS IS A MEANINGFUL
CHANGE ALBEIT SMALL BUT
MEANINGFUL CHANGE WITH REGARD TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
IN THE MIDST OF A CHANGES FROM
FOR PROFIT TO NONPROFIT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE STUDENTS NEED
TO BE -- YOU KNOW.
OVERSIGHT IS TO BE HAD TO MAKE
SURE THE STUDENTS ARE PROTECTED
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
ALL RIGHT ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC --
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE ANY -- INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE NO MEMBER THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
FLOOR -- WE HAVE A A MOTION BY
SENATOR ALSO ANY COMMENTS.
FROM THOSE REMAINING.
WE HAVE A QUESTION PLEASE THERE
GONZALEZ YOU JUST EXPLAIN --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I KNOW IT'S A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE BUT CAN YOU
EXPLAIN AS A V. O. IS THE ONLY
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT AND
THERE'S ASSERTING THAT THERE IS
ALREADY AN EXTENSIVE REVIEW
PROCESS -- BUT CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THAT OF IT YEAH WE A. B. WE
FINALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS A AT THAT THAT PROCESS WHICH
IS THE IMPETUS FOR THE BILL AS
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD FROM HILL
COLLEGES IN THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS THAT WERE IMPACTED.
WITH MANY OF THESE -- DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSITION IN BANKRUPTCY AS THE
STUDENTS ARE AT FAULT -- ARE BY
PUT IN A POSITION TO WHICH THEN --
THERE AND FINANCIAL RUIN AND OF
COURSE WE CANNOT YOU TRANSFERRED
OF THE UNIT SO THIS IS THE TYPE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
TO PROVIDE THE STATE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
HAVE A COUNTY SIMILAR TO THAT OF
SALES OF HOSPITALS AS WELL. FOR
THAT COMMUNITY BENEFITS SO
THAT'S THE IMPETUS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT BECAUSE WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH ACCOUNT BUILDING
TRANSPARENT IN THIS PROCESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT -- THE MOTION IS.
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
THE WINDOW TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECTOR DICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON.
GORGEOUS -- RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES MORNING STERN
UMBERG CASKEY. TWO TWO ZERO TWO
TO ZERO ARE THE BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL.
AND LOOKS LIKE I'M LOSING MY
SUCCESSOR CHAIR.
THIS IS BECOMING COMICAL
FISCALLY -- YEAH DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBER.
ARE THEY DOING.
YOU CAN JUST [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHERE IS THAT THE BEST?
ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK -- AND
EVERYONE CN TELL WE'RE WAITING
ON SOME FOLKS AND WE'RE ALSO
WAITING ON PRESENTERS -- SO I
THINK WE'RE JUST GONNA.
BE A HOLDING PATTERN FOR IF A
FEW MINUTES.
YOU DON'T BY [inaudible]
PERFECT.
IS THAT IT.
THE FACT THAT [inaudile]
THAT.
IS JACK DILLINGER.
HOW ARE YOU?
WELCOME WE KEPT THE WE KEPT
EVERYTHING ON HOLD JUST FOR YOU.
THANK YOU JUST LOOK [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
WHAT I NUMBERS?
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB.
TEN NINETY TWO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IF YOU COULD.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND IN THOSE
THAT ARE WITH YOU WILL BE GIVEN
TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU -- I AM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REGGIE JONES SAWYER AND
PRESENTING AB.
TEN NINETY TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS.
INSIDE JOKE.
TO AND EVERYBODY LATER AB TEN
NINETY TWO SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
POOREST FAMILIES BY ELIMINATING
THE INTEREST ON CHILD SUPPORT
THAT -- TO THE STATE.
UNDER CURRENT CHILD SUPPORT
SYSTEM MOST OF MONEY PAID BY LOW
INCOME PARENTS DOES NOT GO TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
ONLY CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA
ONLY FIFTY DOLLARS OF A CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENT GOES TO THE
FAMILY TO SUPPORT THE CHILDREN
TO REMAINING BALANCE GO TO PAY
BACK TO GOVERNMENT FOR THE
FAMILIES PARTICIPATION OF PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
LIKE HOW IT WORKS WHEN A PARENT
FAILS TO MAKE A TIMELY CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENT THEIR CREW
GOVERNMENT'S DEBT.
AND OUR CHARGE 2% INTEREST ONE
OF THE HIGHEST CHILD SUPPORT
INTEREST IN THE NATION.
DATA SHOW THAT THREE POINT NINE
BILLION OF THE STATE'S
OUTSTANDING CHILD SUPPORT DEBT
IS UNPAID INTEREST FURTHERMORE
BECAUSE THE DEBT IS OWED TO THE
GOVERNMENT LAWS TO PROTECT
AGAINST WAGE GARNISHMENT DO NOT
APPLY.
CHARGING INTEREST ON DEBT -- TO
THE GOVERNMENT DOES NOTHING TO
BENEFIT FAMILIES THESE POLICIES
ACTUALLY RESULT IN LOWERING
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT RATES
DRIVING NONCUSTODIAL PARENT TO
EXIT THE FORMER ECONOMY TO AVOID
WAGE GARNISHMENT.
AND DECREASING PARENTS VISIT TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
AB TEN NINETY TWO WHAT REQUIRE
THE STATE TO CHARGE ZERO
INTEREST ON CHILD SUPPORT DEBT
OWED TO THE GOVERNMENT IN DOING
SO THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT MORE CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
GO TOWARD SUPPORTING CHILDREN
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS MEASURE I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES I WOULD LET THEM
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR BY.
BOAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE I'M SHARING NOW SO
YOUR HEAD AND PASS THAT ON HERE
THANK YOU.
LETTERS SENATORS MY NAME IS
THOMAS LAMB SAMA ELECTRICAL
MAINTENANCE SUPERVISOR FOR MAJOR
FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE I'M A
FATHER OF TWO GIRLS ARE JANA WHO
IS TEEN RHIANNON WHO IS.
pTHEY'VE CHANGED MY LIFE AND I'VE
BEEN SUPPORTING AND CARING FOR
THEM SINCE BIRTH.
EVEN AFTER THE SEPARATION FROM
THEIR MOTHER.
SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN FINDING FOR
CUSTODY AND NOW I HAVE FIFTY
FIFTY JOINT LEGAL AND PHYSICAL
CUSTODY AND DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS THEY LIVE WITH ME.
I WAS BUT INITIALLY PAYING OVER
A THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
CHILD SUPPORT UNAWARE THAT MOST
OF THE MONEY WASN'T MAKING IT TO
MY KEYS BUT REPAYING THE
GOVERNMENT BACK FOR THE WELFARE.
AND CASH AID ASSISTANCE THEIR
MOTHER WAS RECEIVING FOR AWHILE.
I FELL BEHIND TO THE INTEREST
RATES BEING UNREASONABLY HIGH I
DIDN'T SEE HOW IT WAS FEASIBLE
TO EVER CATCH A I WAS ANGRY AND
FEELING LIKE I FEEL MY KIDS
BECAUSE THE CHILD SUPPORT COMING
FROM MY CHECKS WASN'T ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING.
MY CHILDREN.
THEN I A ROAD IN A PILOT PROGRAM
WHERE THEY ELIMINATED THE
GOVERNMENT -- DEBT AND ALLOW MY
CHILD SUPPORT TO ACTUALLY GET TO
MY CHILDREN AND MOTHER. TO HELP
THEM AND IT WAS MORE USEFUL I'M
GRATEFUL AND I FEEL BLESSED TO
BE A PART OF THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT ALLOWED ME TO STAY
CURRENT ON MY PAYMENTS AND IS
CREATING THE FINANCIAL STABILITY.
BETWEEN US AS PARENTS TO PROVIDE
FOR OUR CHILDREN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR IS MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL BROWN AND I'M
WITH THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
TREASURER'S OFFICE.
HE CO AUTHORED A REPORT RELEASED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT DESCRIBES
THE IMPACT.
OF THE REQUIREMENT TO REPAY
PUBLIC BENEFITS ON CALIFORNIA'S
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. FOR MANY
FAMILIES LIKE THOMAS'S THE
CHILDREN ON THE RECEIVE THE
FIRST FIFTY DOLLARS OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
AND THE REST IS USED TO
REIMBURSE THE COST OF PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE LIKE MEDICAID ALLEN
CAL WORKS.
WHEN THEY FALL BEHIND ON
PAYMENTS BECAUSE THEIR HOURS
CHANGER THEIR TRANSITIONING JOBS?
THE DEBT QUICKLY SNOWBALLS WITH
10% COMPOUND INTEREST.
FAR WITH 10% INTEREST.
MORE THAN THREE QUARTERS OF
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT ACROSS THE
STATE IS HELD BY SOMEONE WHO
COULDN'T AFFORD TO PAY THEIR
ORIGINAL ORDER.
IN MANY CASES WHICH WAS TWICE
THEIR ANNUAL INCOME.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF THIS
DEBT HAS BEEN DEEMED I'M
COLLECTIBLE AS IT'S OWNED BY A
PARENT WHO OWES WHO EARNS LESS
THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
IN ANNUAL INCOME.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH ADULT CHILDREN
WHO ARE HELPING THEIR PARENTS
PAY OFF THIS PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PAY BACK THAT.
AS THEIR PARENTS AGE AND SPOKEN
WITH PARENTS WHO CAN'T FIND.
HOUSING OR JOBS OR BETTER
SITUATIONS FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACT THAT THE STATE HAS.
ON THEIR CREDIT SCORE IN ON
THEIR OVERALL FINANCES.
FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
STATE TO CHARGE INTEREST ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PAY BACK DEBT
AND YET CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST
RATE.
IS AMONGST THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION A RATE HIGHER THAN TEXAS
MISSISSIPPI AND VIRGINIA.
OVERALL RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
REQUIRING PARENTS TO PAY BACK
THE COST OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
DEPRIVE LOW INCOME CHILDREN OF
VALUABLE RESOURCES WIDENS THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP AND CREATE
CONFLICT IN FAMILIES.
CHARGING 10% INTEREST ON TOP OF
THIS COMPOUNDS ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
AB TEN NINETY TWO WILL PREVENT
THAT FROM BALLOONING OVER TIME
AND ALLOW MORE RESOURCES TO GO
WHERE IT SHOULD WHICH IS TO
CHILDREN.
THE RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY AND SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES OF SUPPORT -- THAT
CAN COME FORWARD.
I'M SORRY WAS THERE ONE OTHER
PERSON HAVE A TELEVISED THAT'S
OKAY THANK YOU SHOWN A JESSICA
BARTH Là WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE ARE
A CO SPONSOR WITH TIPPING POINTS.
POLICY LINK THE GOOD PLUS
FOUNDATION ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ALL OF US ARE NONE
LEGAL SERVICES FOR FOR PRISONERS
WITHCHILDREN INSIDE CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND A FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT
THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL COMMENCE WITH THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE OF
MARYLAND IN BREED IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
HI SABRINA HAMMER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSET BUILDING COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS FUNDING AS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION A PRO CO
SPONSOR.
THANK.
THANK YOU AND ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN A SUPPORT
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THERE ARE --
AT THIS POINT BUT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE A CALL THAT OUT.
GREAT -- SO WE'LL GO HEAD BACK
BEHIND THE DYESS ARE THERE ANY
POINTS OF DISCUSSION.
NO QUESTIONS OKAY PREPARED TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME OKAY GREAT.
WONDERFUL AND I WANTED TO THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK --
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT MORE STRINGENT THAN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT THIS
POINT SPEAKS A LOT AND I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CORRECT IN SAYING THAT.
THE IMPACT IT HAS ON COMMUNITIES
LIKE OURS -- IS A REAL.
A GOOD THING SO THANK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE BOAT.
OKAY AND SO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
A DO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AT THIS POINT.
IS THAT IT ALRIGHT AND WE'RE
GOOD WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR NOW I
NEED TO OKAY AND SHE'LL CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TO
NINETY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
JACKSON.
GORGEOUS BRUSSEL GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
AT GONZALEZ I'D JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN UMBERG UMBERG
I'D WHITE HOUSE SKI.
OKAY WE HAVE A THREE TWO ZERO
VOTE AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS JONES
SAWYER.
YOU.
TO GET.
TO ALL RIGHT WILL BRING UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUESTS. FOR BY.
ONE AND THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES.
MAKE SIDED -- TO BE HERE AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL -- SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT LEGISLATION RELATED
TO OUR STATE ATTORNEY GNERAL
AND THE BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
AND AS PREVIOUS AS A A PREVIOUS
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL STATED.
TOO FREQUENTLY.
THIS STATES LOWER INCOME -- THE
THE COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR EXPERIENCE FAR GREATER
IMPACTS FROM POLLUTION.
TOXIC -- CONTENT CONTAMINATION
AND YOUR FOOT IN THE EFFECTS OF
GLOBAL WARMING MORE SO THAN
WEALTHIER MORE FLUENT AREAS OF
THE STATE.
AND SO THE US THESE CALIFORNIANS
THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED A KEY ROLE
OR A VOICE IN THE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THE QUALITY OF THEIR
LIVES.
AND SO AS A RESULT THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY TWENTY THREE
IT DOES TWO THINGS.
THE FIRST IS IT WOULD ADD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE DOJ'S
BUREAU VINYL JUSTICE TO THE LIST
OF AGENCIES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
MUST COORDINATE WITH REGARDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS.
AND THE SECOND THING IS THIS
BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO SURE THAT --
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT OCCURS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT SENDS A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT IMPACTED
LOCALITIES AND THOSE COMMUNITIES
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE NOTIFIED.
AND INCLUDED WHEN IT COMES TO
LOCAL PLANNING -- THAT MAY
AFFECT THEIR HEALTH AND
LIVELIHOODS AND SO CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE ENVIRONMENT DOES
APPEAR TO BE CONSULTED AND TO
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE WITH --
OUR STATE'S CORN AB AGENCY FROM
FINAL JUSTICE PROGRAMS -- IT'S
YOU KNOW THAT'S A BIG DEAL AND I
STRONGLY.
BELIEVE THAT THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WILL RESULT IN EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS.
AND BETTER OUTCOMES MAYBE NOT
FOR EVERY DISTRICT OR THE
CONSTITUENCY THAT WE SERVE IN
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY.
BUT IT ABSOLUTELY WILL FOR THE
PEOPLE I REPRESENT AND IT
ABSOLUTELY WILL FOR THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS -- WHO LIVE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF SOME OF THE
MOST -- THE POLLUTED AREAS IN
OUR STATE.
I AND SO CERTAINLY -- I HAVE THE
BILL SPONSORS HERE WILL ALLOW
THEM TO DO OME SELVES BUT
CERTAINLY -- AND RESPECT WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CHELSEA TO I'M A
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY IN ENVIRONMENT.
HE IS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT CLP
WHERE AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
INCLUDING KERN AND TULARE
COUNTIES.
RESIDENTS IN THE VALLEY
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SUFFER FROM SEVERE ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS THE LIVE NEXT TO AND ARE
CONSTANTLY EXPOSED TO TOXIC
PESTICIDES AND THOUSANDS OF
ACTIVE OIL AND GAS WELLS.
AND SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS YOUR PC HAS
WORKED WITH THESE COMMUNITIES TO
REDUCE THE DISPROPORTIONATE
POLLUTION AND SOCIO ECONOMIC
BURDENS.
BUT THESE COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
ON A DAILY BASIS AND THAT IS WHY
WE ARE PROUD TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
BUT FOSTER FURTHER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AN ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BUREAU TO
ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED AGENCIES ARE
CONTINUING TO PRIORITIZE AND
WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH OF THE
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
FURTHER MORE THIS BILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE DEFINITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SO THAT IT
WOULD EMBODY THE KEY PRINCIPLE
THAT FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
SHOULD NOT ONLY BE IN THE ROOM
BUT MUST ALSO BE ACTIVE PARTNERS
IN MAKING DECISIONS THAT AFFECT
THE HEALTH OF THEIR FAMILIES.
MOST IMPORTANTLY AGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DOORS
TOXIC BURNS THE STATEFOR TOO
LONG.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
RECOGNIZES AND PROMOTES THE
ALTMAN GOAL OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO PREVENT REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE POLLUTION BURDENS IN
THE MOST POLLUTED COMMUNITIES.
IN SOME AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THAT'S THE NECESSARY GOLD
STANDARD FOR ACHIEVING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SO THAT
EVERY FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA CAN
ENJOY A CLEAN AIR WATER IN THE
END.
WE LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE I IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SIR CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION -- BACK IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE COAST LACK
WAS ACTUALLY AMENDED TO
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZE THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN ITS
PERMIT DECISIONS.
THE COMMISSION SUPPORTED THAT
POLICY CHANGE BECAUSE THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES WHERE PROJECTS
HAVE COME BEFORE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THAT.
OF ESSENTIALLY MEET ALL THE
COSTA LACK REQUIREMENTS BUT
STILL VISIT AN UNACCEPTABLE
LEVEL OF HARM -- ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BEYOND
COASTAL ACT ISSUES SO -- BACK IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE INTRODUCED AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTEEN TO OF SORT OF OF CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE IF YOU WILL IS TO
SPECIFICALLY SAY THAT YES.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROVISIONS
OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE DO APPLY
TO THE CONSOLE ACOSTA LACK IN
THE COMMISSION CAN USE.
THAT DEFINITION TO CONSIDER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN ITS
PERMIT DECISIONS -- THE AGENCY
WAS ACTUALLY SO ENTHUSIASTIC TO
GET THAT POLICY ARE IMPLEMENTED
THAT WE SORT OF JUMPED THE GUN A
LITTLE BIT AND TOOK A POLICY TO
THE COMMISSION IN.
MARCH OF THAT YEAR -- OF OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONCE IT WAS
ENACTED.
AND BECAUSE WE WANTED TO GO TO
GET STARTED AND WE WERE.
TOLD CANTLEY BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
THAT THAT ISN'T ACTUALLY HOW AN
AGENCY SHOULD PREPARED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE POLICY WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE ENGAGING THE
COMMUNITIES THERE COULD BE
AFFECTED.
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE A ROLL OF
MEANINGFUL ROLE TO PLAY IN THE
SHAPING OF THAT POLICY.
SO WE TOOK A DEEP BREATH AND WE
STEP BACK AND WE SPENT THE NEXT
TWO YEARS REACHING OUT DIRECTLY.
TO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
COASTAL ZONE MEETING WITH THEM
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AT THEIR
REQUEST -- EXPLAINING TO THEM AT
AND IS ABOUT THE ABOUT THE
COASTAL ACT AND THE POLICY IN
HEARING FROM THEM BUT WHAT WOULD
BE MEANINGFUL FOR THEM AND WHAT
THEY REALLY NEED TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO DO BETTER AND
DIFFERENTLY. TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS.
GOING FORWARD AND SO I'M VERY
APPY TO SAY THAT THAT EFFORT
RESULTED IN THE COMMISSION
ADOPTING A MUCH STRONGER POLICY
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHY THE ITEMS ARE TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL WE CAN JUST
WRAP UP GREAT.
MEANING FULL -- INVOLVEMENT WITH
COMMUNITIES IS ESSENTIAL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION THE COMMISSION
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
AND WE HOPE YOU DO TOO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND IF WE CAN BRING EVERYONE UP
WHO IS IN A SUPPORT PLEASE.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE CUT
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT.
TIFFANY ANGUISHING SUPPORT FOR
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES.
THE END OF OSCARS REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COALITION. THIRTY FONG
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
A VARIETY OF ANY OTHER WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS.
US SENATOR MONNING.
AND I WANT TO THANK A CENTER
GONZALEZ FOR TAKING THE GAVEL.
WE'VE BEEN A LITTLE SPARSE HERE
THIS AFTERNOON BUT STILL MIGHTY
SO.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE -- GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO THINK
CENTER GONZALEZ.
FOR SHARING IN A THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THE FIRST WITNESS I'M STARTING
CATCHER NAME.
MY NAME IS CHELSEA TO MIND
TURNING WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT IN.
ARE YOU BASED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR BAY AREA.
I WORK IN THE OFFICE IN THE BAY
AREA AND OUR PRIMARY OFFICE IS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN KERN
COUNTY THANK YOU.
YOU MADE A REFERENCE TO
PESTICIDES AND I DIDN'T CATCH
THE CONTEXT IN COULD YOU JUST
SHARE WITH ME WHAT THAT WAS.
OF COURSE THE I WAS SHARING THAT
RESIDENTS IN THE VALLEY IN
PARTICULAR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
ON IN.
KERN AND TULARE COUNTIES WHERE
SYRUPY WORKS I SUFFER FROM
SEVERE MARLA HOW HAS HEALTH
HAZARDS INCLUDING EXPOSURE TO
PESTICIDES THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW JUST WITHIN THE LAST
WEEK THERE WAS.
AN EXPOSURE TO TWO HUNDRED
WORKERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
HIS YOUR OFFICE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THAT AT ALL WE WERE AWARE
OF THE SITUATION AND MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WORK ON
PESTICIDES ISSUES -- I THINK
WE'RE TRACKING IT.
AGAIN IT'S ONE OF THE MORE
[inaudible]
FROM.
WELL NOT TO MAKE COMPARISONS BUT
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN AGRICULTURE
WHO FACE WORKPLACE HAZARDS
INCLUDING PESTICIDE IS NOT
LIMITED TO PESTICIDES.
ARE OFTEN THE MOST VOICELESS IN
TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT OF
REGULATIONS AND LAWS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THEM.
OFTEN BECAUSE OF LEGAL STATUS
LANGUAGE EDUCATION.
EXPLOITIVE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIPS -- SO I'M JUST
PLEASE THERE'S ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE YOURS -- PROVIDING THAT
VOICE IN.
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR EXPANDING THIS VOICE INTO
STATUTES SO -- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MAY BE GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
I TO JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
AS WELL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THE GROUPS --
SUPPORTING THIS OF WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER IN LONG BEACH AND
SIMILAR TO YOU HAVE A PORTS AND
REFINERIES -- SOIL CONTAMINATION
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS IS A GREAT.
A WAY TO TO WORK ON ON ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES SO THANKS AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT SINGER NO OTHER --
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN JUST -- WANTING TO
SPONSORS -- FOR FOR ATTENDING
AND CERTAINLY -- QUESTION I
BOUGHT OR YOU KNOW.
ASPEN EITHER THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
I TO AGREE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND EXPANDING IN
PARTICULAR TO STRENGTHENING THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SO THAT -- THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND LAUGH CO -- HAVE
TO CONSIDER THIS WHEN MAKING
THEIR VARIOUS LAND USE DECISIONS
I THINK IS DEFINITELY A
SUBSTANTIAL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND FOR ALL THE OTHER REASONS
MENTIONED SO WITH THAT.
THE OCEAN BY SENATOR MONNING WAS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS A MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE'RE ON
FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN WHICH IS OUR LAST ITEM
TODAY BUT NEXT WEEK WE'VE GOT
OVER FORTY ITEMS SO.
JUST TO GIVE YOU FAIR WARNING
THIS ONE IS THE ABBREVIATED
VERSION IN YOUR THE FINALITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE PORCHES [inaudible]
RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
AMER I WHAT CAL SKI HI MICHAEL
SKI I SIX TWO ZERO SIX TO ZERO
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND IF THE
SERGEANT COULD CALL THEM SO WE
CAN GO THROUGH THE ROLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND TO YOUR
WITNESSES [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible] NINE BOB
[inaudible]
ALL THE IN A WAY.
FOR JONES AND WHO ELSE WHO ARE
THE OTHER APPS
[inaudible]
ON YEAH [inaudible]
PHONE NUMBER.
THE BILL.
HAS [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
THE ORIGINAL
.
SECRETARY LET'S GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE ROLLS ON THE CALENDAR
FOR TODAY LET'S START WITH FILE
ITEM. ONE OR LET'S START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE VOTE
COUNT IS. SIXTY ZERO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JONES STERN.
ZERO EIGHT TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN AND THE WHOLE
PLEASE CENTER JOHNSON BECOMING
DOWN FILE ITEM ONE AB -- ONE
SIXTY ONE BY TING THE VOTE COUNT
IS FORD IS ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
OR JUST NO TO WRESTLE.
JONES STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE [inaudible]
NUMBER HI. SIX WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN AT SIX TO ONE OF THE
FILE ITEM. FOR A. B..
SEVEN FORTY NINE I'M SORRY DID I
MISS.
TO FORGIVE ME BY WILLIS COULD
FILE ITEM TO AB TWO FORTY TWO BY
COM LOG OR DOVE.
THE VOTE COUNT OF SIX TO ZERO
JONES.
THE SAME FILE ITEM TO VOTE COUNT
AS SIX TO ZERO JONES STERN.
STERN AYE AMBER.
AMBER GUY RIGHT THE VOTE COUNT
IS A TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT
ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES
NEXT IS.
FILE ITEM FOR A. B. SEVEN FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
THE VOTE COUNT IS. THREE TO ONE
OF PLEASE.
UGH CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE JONES
STERN.
STERN AYE AMBERG.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY WHAT HOUSE
KEY AYE RIGHT SEVEN TO ONE WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
FILE ITEM. SEVEN AB TEN NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
THE VOTE COUNT IS CURRENTLY
THREE TO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON HI
JACKSON I BORDERS [inaudible]
RUSSELL [inaudible]
JONES STERN.
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI BY CASKEY I
BY THE ACCOUNT IS FIVE TWO ZERO
WILL LEAVE THEIR ROLL CALL OPEN.
OF FILE ITEM EIGHT ONE FILE ITEM
H. A. B. ELEVEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH PLEASE.
THE BILL COMES FORTY ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE STERN.
TURN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER OF IOWA CASKEY HI WHAT
HAS HE AYE JONES. EIGHT ZERO ALL
RIGHT -- LET'S CALL THAT ONE ONE
MORE TIME SINCE -- WE DO HAVE A
FULL HOUSE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WERE ON FILE ITEM.
EIGHT A. B.. ELEVEN OH SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES.
JONES I NINE EIGHT NINE TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
THE VOTE COUNT IS FIVE TWO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS. FOR JUST BY JONES
JONES I STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
NUMBER BY. NINE ZERO NINE TWO
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY TWO THE VOTE COUNT IS TWO
TWO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE BORDERS
[inaudible]
JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
NUMBER TWO I WOULD CAL SKI.
MAKOVSKY AYE ALL RIGHT THE SEVEN
TWO ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THE VOTE COUNT
IS.
THREE TO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON HI
JACKSON I'D JONES.
JONES I'M MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE NUMBER I WHITE
HOUSE SKI I KELSEY I NINE TWO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS THE
VOTE COUNT IS. SIXTY ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I JONES.
JONES NO RIGHT OF AND ONE SEVEN
TO ONE THAT BILL IS SHOUT WILL
GO THROUGH THE THE FIRST EIGHT
TWITCHES.
WHERE WE STILL HAVE?
ARE OPEN OPEN VOTING FILE ITEM
OF ONE DO WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LET'S CALL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR JONES.
JONES I NINE TWO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO.
FILE ITEM ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D JONES.
JONES NO FILE ARCHES ME SEVEN TO
TO THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TO
A. B. TWO FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER JONES.
EXCUSE ME TO OF PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON OR I'M
SORRY JONES.
OKAY A TWO ZERO EIGHT TWO ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT FILE ITEM FOR AB
SEVEN FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE THE VOTE COUNTY IS
SEVEN TO ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES.
JONES NO SEVENTY TWO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
LAST.
ONE IS FILE ITEM.
SEVEN AB TEN NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER THE
VOTE COUNT IS FIVE TWO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS.
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D JONES [inaudible]
JONES NO. THREE SEVEN TWO TO ONE
THAT BILL SEVEN TO ONE RATHER
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU STAFF.
THANK YOU TO THE SERGEANTS THANK
YOU TO MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNED